[Music]
look what I become
okay so today's guest for those of you
that uh uh know him he doesn't need an
introduction you love him you hate them
uh it's so funny I was asking one of the
guys in here I said so Andres what do
you think about you know Alex Jones he
says well based on the viral Clips I've
seen he he he looks like he's crazy
based on some of the stuff that he says
he says I don't know much about it
that's all I know what the media says
about him this is a guy that doesn't
follow politics the last time you and I
were together I think it was a day or
two after you had gotten banned we sat
down in Austin we had a it was a
different kind of a conversation we had
in Austin it was uh uh you were eating
apples if you remember you were biting
that Apple we were going it was an
intense conversation we had but it was a
good one and it was late in the evening
I'd been up for like since 5am I was
exhausted but it was it was a good
discussion yes and and I'm glad we're
able to do it now obviously that's four
or five years later since the last
conversation we got a lot to cover with
you it's so interesting with the timing
of it right now is uh you know with
what's going on with the Wagner group or
what
number one story uh across the world I
mean this could lead to nuclear war very
easily that's why I'm glad we're
actually in a vault with like five we're
safe here we're safe here we'll die out
there of the new kids we got that story
we got RFK uh comments he's made and I
know your fans you're a fan of some of
the stuff he talked about we'll get into
that as well Bohemian Grove some of the
things with uh that maybe you know a lot
of people have no stories of it but
we'll edit again from a different angle
the Navy uh confirming they knew the sub
was going down I think Coast Guard knew
as of last Sunday but none of us know
about it we're thinking I have 40 more
hours all this other so we'll talk about
that Karine jean-pierre's a questioning
this last uh I think it was even
yesterday it was yesterday it was
amazing back and forth and she just
didn't want to answer any of it I think
Kirby got it Kirby walked off yeah he
walked off a prediction you made March
8th of this year that came true will
play that clip and we got a few other
things but this is the first thing I
want to talk about from my standpoint so
Sandy Hook we're not talking Sandy Hook
what I want to talk to you about is they
came out if he can pull up this article
with a fine of this is San Diego
families want Alex Jones to pay up
2.75 trillion dollars in Damages as he
seeks neutral so here's a question I got
for you
either you're the richest man in the
world and we don't know that how do they
collect that kind of money how do they
come up with a number like this to
collect from you and then they run
articles in New York Times Shang Jones
refuses to pay
how am I that's like that's the GDP of
like Scotland
Jones refused more more than that or
France actually India's GDP is exactly
three trillion dollars so they want you
to pay India's GDP which is a billion
500 million people yeah I'm not lobbying
and they say why does he laugh well
here's the thing I was found this is
very interesting this is a new thing if
you wonder why Fox
settled Dominion for 700 and something
million right as the trial started over
question the election uh which we're not
doing obviously all elections are free
and fair Biden's the greatest president
ever uh I'm serious I love him man and
the shots are wonderful take them all
take hundreds of them yeah but but
seriously TMO is wonderful I would say
it's wonderful uh uh uh 100 Biden's
great yeah anyway the level of his
laptop
no problem what they do is they insert
in jurisdictions like Austin Energy
Connecticut and DC
they go in and and this was in the case
uh with uh or Delaware with uh with the
fox and they the the judge defaults you
the judge defaults you and says the jury
you're guilty well the judge didn't call
the default in Dominion with with Fox
the judge said I'm saying you're guilty
and you did lie about the election and
I'm going to tell the jury that I'm
gonna we're gonna start it from that
point so she did like a soft default
with them that's when they went Whoa We
settled well with me they did a hard
default said I gave them no information
No I gave them four years of stuff gave
them everything they wanted and then
they had no case because I never made up
any other stuff that they said that I
said and I couldn't put a defense on the
jury's only heard I'm guilty now decide
how much then they put Financial experts
on that never examined our books didn't
want to look at our books and said I was
worth 400 million dollars at the time of
that first trial I had about two million
dollars in the bank and then some real
estate that's it yeah it's all lies it's
all like sure I've had gross sales of of
60 million dollars before but when
you're selling you know water filters
you're only making 30 on them because
you give them a good price yeah I mean
I've sold 10 million dollars of water
filters a year and then I and we end up
after everything you know getting a
couple million then I'd probably get a
couple hundred thousand out of that so
you know how businesses you don't get
the gross amount and so uh they they
look back over the fact that we'd made
yeah I mean probably like 600 700
million dollars in the last uh 10 12
years and they just said look he kept
400 million and then the juries went
well fine then maybe give them a billion
and then they went back to the judge and
said 1.5 billion in Connecticut's not
enough they said and that's why it's in
Bloomberg this is not a joke folks they
said well no he we want 2.75 trillion
how did they come up with that number
though uh they gave an FBI agent who I
never heard his name never talked about
him they had none of me on air none of
my crew no articles He's listed the
lawsuit from Connecticut first time to
read his name and he got 90 plus million
for me and the law says in Connecticut
in Texas you can't system they didn't
say your name the judges waved it and
said we don't care
look it up 90 he got 95 million dollars
I'd never seen him did not know his name
till I get the lawsuit and I Google his
name
and he said on the stand he got one
phone call at his office to make sure he
was really an FBI agent and he said and
that was because of me I didn't even
know who the guy was the called then the
guy that called his office showed up the
court and I found his videos on YouTube
Just a polite guy calling up saying hey
people say this didn't happen I'm just
calling to check your really FBI agent
and the jury said 90 something million
dollars you got one phone call
I want to get one of these phone calls
if I get 90 million dollars for it Alex
these numbers seem outrageous whether
it's a half a billion dollars a billion
dollars a trillion dollars and by the
way the medial say I'm denying it four
years ago on your show I said I thought
it happened I said it uh seven years ago
I thought it happened but here's my
question took a few things out of
context and blew it up here's my
question Alex whatever the outrageous
number is you're saying you were never
even worth anything we're close to that
all right
you filed for bankruptcy after that
right yes so walk me through the process
the judges wouldn't let me tell the jury
the judge of Connecticut said six months
in jail
contempt she gave me a list of 20 plus
things cannot say I'm innocent this is
on TV and they would cut away at those
points
cannot say I'm innocent cannot say I'm
in bankruptcy and cannot present sworn
Federal documents and my bank accounts
would you go to jail if you lie
bankruptcy yeah so now walk us through
what happens when you're when you're
bankrupt for a billion a trillion
dollars what what happens then I mean
it's like if somebody says I'm gonna
shoot you once I'm like please don't I'm
gonna shoot you five times and I'm like
please don't we're gonna shoot you 500
times you're just like that's ridiculous
I'm okay ten times and 500 times it
becomes
preposterous and just it just shows the
excesses of the hysteria that's the the
that's going on does it preclude you
from making more money now how does that
work I generally don't understand when
you're when you file for bankruptcy and
you're quote unquote owed a trillion
dollars what are the outrageous number
is do they seize your assets do they do
they seize your bank accounts how do you
even pay this
um I mean here's the thing I've never
lived super opulently I mean I got a
nice car house full swimming pool and
you know I can get a good steak for 50
bucks I mean I've never so I mean I used
to take the money we'd have and put into
advertising and promotion and and and
and buy ads in order to promote my show
because I wanted to get the word out and
so it's really just an engine of getting
the word out I was trying to make a
bunch of money to build the media
infrastructure that was my real goal and
then and then you know just like any
business that's the goal of the business
and then the mission but I wasn't doing
it as a business it was a business to
make money to get the word out and it's
fine to make money but my real motive
was always to you know expose the
globalist not have world war three have
sovereignty have a good country for my
children a good world to grow up in and
I was exposing interesting crazy things
that I knew about and and having fun
while I was doing it no but that doesn't
really answer the question because I
understand your motivation to make the
money how do you repay the money the
quote-unquote billion dollars oh yeah
well that's how does that work that's a
prima facial answer obviously I don't
okay I mean I just said I I mean the
court has said I can be paid if I want
to stay at Free Speech systems let it
keep going uh a million and a half
dollars a year right now well my legal
bills are over a million and a half
dollars a year it's crazy so I basically
work for free now uh I had my house it's
homesteaded uh and uh that's basically
that's why I've run out of money and
then that's a big question and they've
now admitted the lawyers in both cases
in Texas and Connecticut said on the
courthouse steps our goal is not to get
this money our goal is to silence him
yeah so if you if you do you know Joe
Lewis's story what happened to him at
the tail end of his career the boxer the
boxer so Joe Lewis the IRS came after
this if you just type in Joe Joe Lewis
type in Joe Lewis IRS poverty if you
just type that in so it's an incredible
story yeah it's an incredible story this
is a guy that's a legend go to the
second one Claremont Review of Books
it's a New York Times story I'm looking
at here
um this guy had the the IRS came after
him so much that eventually he's like
dude I can't pay this back
and then the way Joe Lewis's career
ended is he was in Vegas he got hired by
his friends they gave him a place to
live they gave him food and all he did
is greet people when they came in this
was a form of shutting somebody down and
hey just go sit there you know the whole
thing about shut up and uh shut up and
drink because he was a republican Joe
Lewis that's kind of where I was going
I'm sorry yeah go ahead well I mean for
people because because I've read the
stories I want to read the book but but
I knew about the it's even like
documentaries even on History Channel
that I saw like 20 years ago so this is
not debated
he he basically donated all his proceeds
you know when he like you know beat the
famous no you know Nazi and all this
stuff
to the U.S government and to the
military and you get all the finer
details there because I haven't read the
story in years and then the IRS came
back and said well actually you owe
taxes on that gift uh to to to the
Troops and and to all this and into the
military and then hounded him and said
if you just stopped being a republican
we will drop all of this and that shows
how dirty the Democrats have been along
dude it's a good if you can stay on that
Rob right there so during the war Lewis
fought 96 exhibition matches before more
than two million troops he also donated
more than a hundred thousand dollars to
the Army and Navy Relief efforts he
reached the ranks of Sergeant in 1945
the Legion of Merit for his
contributions anyways they came back to
this guy the story's a technical story
too yeah to back to back taxes to just
Silas them and say just don't do
anything so my question is okay with him
back then they had their reasons why do
you constantly find yourself getting in
trouble what what is it about Alex Jones
some will say Well they're afraid of
what Alex has to say because Alex is
exposing them did you see what Alex did
Alex talked about 9 11 in in July and it
happened four months later how did he
know you know that this was going to
happen two months later how did he know
when he talked about in the video you
know how did he know about this and how
did he know about that you know some of
the stories with the Skull and Bones
society you've talked about the big form
on the government the cashless Society
the you know government surveillance
Epstein high profile you've talked about
all that stuff and some of the stuff
with vaccine got you in trouble with you
know Sandy Hook with the pizza with all
these other things but why why do you
think they
are trying to do this to 2.75 trillion
when when even a regular person hears it
they're like this is ludicrous
ridiculous type of numbers what do they
fear the most with you
well I've made mistakes and I've gotten
some things wrong and I never did it on
purpose and then what they do is it's
like having a magnifying glass or a
microscope and a grain of sand it looks
like a mountain when you look at it so
they blow up these things on my timeline
and and what they did is that we now
know what happened
um they they tried to censor us and
block us and stuff over the years so we
broke a lot of big stories and a lot of
great research and a lot of great guests
on and broke a lot of original important
news and our accuracy was way above 95
and then Trump comes along
and when we went to the RNC in Cleveland
and about a third of the people that
showed up in the streets about I'd say
about 50 60 000 in the streets
that's outside the convention we're all
wearing Infowars shirts and Alex Jones
shirts because we'd had a lot of shirts
going out we'd sold 300 400 500 000 of
just one shirt uh about Hillary for
president but we sold it at cost for
five dollars and so there was I'd say 10
000 Hillary for prison shirts there and
there were thousands inside and and so
you've got all these reporters there
there's no counter demonstration pull up
those shirts Rob so we can see what it
looks like oh I keep going and so all
there was was and then of course the
news reported on this they're like
there's a sea of infowar shirts and a
sea of Hillary for prison shirts
and and then when when Trump won
um they'd already started the Russian
investigation saying everybody was a
Russian agent so now we know it's been
Declassified that they said I was a
Russian agent Trump was a Russian agent
it was all fake and then they were able
to declare National Security this came
out in Congress three months ago and put
the CIA on us so the CIA through law
firms and through uh PR firms they've
now bragged after the cases about this
they had a big Time magazine article
about it and they had a uh and then the
pr firms one of the largest in the
country just caught by the biggest they
do the pr for the U.N after the
judgments they went okay we did it we're
the Geniuses we're the best we went and
found something that made him look bad
blew it up had the media all reported
and then make it hurtful to people that
it was them blowing it up then demonize
me say that I was Trump's right-hand man
to demonize Trump and then basically set
the precedent that they could take me
down they could then take everybody else
down that if folks allowed me to be
taken down they also mentioned Julian
Assange in the documents if they could
shut me him down and have the left agree
with it and have the right agree with me
being shut down it would set the
president to knock down all the dominoes
so I was chosen this is the art time of
see it's good we're going to censor him
and then as soon as they were done with
me they moved on to everybody else and
so I was just chosen as the test pilot
for this Alex upbringing let's go back
to 10 years old 12 years old everybody
has an influence right for me my
mother's family they were all Communists
my dad's family they were imperialists
for you to be this much of a True
Believer what was the conversations like
at the kitchen table with Mom and Dad
what did you guys talk about
uh well there was full mobilization in
the Cold War across the country but
particularly places like Texas uh and uh
in the South and so I mean I would go to
family reunions and it was like a
soldier of fortune convention uh and so
uh a lot of the family had been you know
obviously in World War II Korea Vietnam
and a lot of them had been um you know
operatives in the CIA and things like
that but to me you're a kid and when the
family reunion's going on you know I'm
just uh you know getting a four-wheeler
and you know taking a shotgun off and
shooting birds I'm not you know hanging
out with all these old men and then a
lot of family on my dad's side that had
done stuff for the government uh in
operations not just around the world but
here because back then it was all human
intelligence by the 90s it went to
digital stuff but before that you had to
have a lot of muscle on the ground a lot
of people people that don't know the
Army you know all over the world but
also in the US would go around you know
killed people it was like extrajudicial
Senators would sign off on letters and
they would and then they said well
usually army officers off to kill people
so like when you see the movie
um uh well what's that movie with uh all
the great actors uh Apocalypse Now where
he you know they have the Army captain
and then they're sending them to Kill
Colonel Kurtz that's a fictional story
but that's actually how it works the
biggest Hitman group in in the United
States or the world would be like army
officers like that sick like oh the
Italian mafia's got a hundred Hitman
well they've got ten thousand so and and
then my uh I had when my dad had a guy
who called you like his uncle was
released a cousin 10 years older that
lived across the street and he only told
my dad about this later and stuff but
that was one of his jobs and then my
mom's uh brother I've been an army
officer and uh he was involved in Iran
Contra a bunch of Black Ops but he was
involved in like being in charge of
things building airfields in Central and
South America uh and so he was the one
that really told me about all this stuff
and then and then my dad
had got recruited into the academic arm
of the stuff uh in it was it was like
above the CIA in like plan two at
University of Texas when he was like 14
15. he was already going to University
of Texas because he was he because he
was winning all these Awards and had top
you know perfect score and uh his mom
thought he was going to when he was like
14 to get to take tests to be in NASA in
this and and Eisenhower's whiz kid
program but it wasn't Eisenhower it
wasn't a whiz kids program to be in NASA
and so my dad got into that for a while
he never told me what he did and they
decided like to get out of it and just
be a doctor at a certain point uh but he
the house was just full of all this big
Brzezinski books and Henry Kissinger
stuff and just World politics and you
know just military manuals and just
stuff everywhere and my dad was just
always racist reading and so I just grew
up basically around all this stuff and
it was particularly my mom's
um brother who died about nine years ago
really smart guy uh who uh got out of it
and uh and then when he was
dying of pneumonia last time I saw him I
thought he was gonna live and he was
dead a week later
um he just said well I want you to know
the stuff about them trafficking kids is
true and that's why I got out of what I
was doing in Central America uh because
uh you know they were they were
smuggling kids out of orphanages and
doing terrible things with them and we
just knew about your this is your mom's
brother my mom's brother and of course
remember this is nine years ago before
all the migrant crisis the kids and the
current smuggling he was seeing it down
there and he said he and a bunch of his
guys uh got out of it uh some of the
guys he was with the government killed
and what was his background your uncle
uh he was a helicopter pilot in Vietnam
and uh and mainly delivered Special
Forces troops into Laos and he worked
for him you know he uh my mom doesn't
like me telling this stuff because he
told her about it didn't tell me and she
says you know it's embarrassing the
family but you know he uh I mean he was
doing whatever he's told Vietnam and it
was it was it was smuggling your opium
your mom and dad when they saw you when
you first got into you've been in the
space of uh in full Wars in which you've
been knew for how long 30 years 28 years
25 years 29 years 29 years okay
so when you first got in I was 20 years
old you were 20 years old okay so what
was their initial reaction to was it
like Alex what are you doing and there
was a we believe in you we agree with
you you're talking too much but relax
this is you're going overboard what was
their reaction to this when you first
got started uh my dad for the first five
six seven years was just sometimes say
you need to be careful what you're doing
and you could get killed doing this he
said one time he said I could have you
talk to some people and get you out of
this right now but he said I said the
government's bad he said they are bad
they got to do bad things to protect
this country they're in charge because
they're smart and and they're smarter
than us what a thing to say and and yeah
yeah they got to do bad things to
protect the country yeah and and well
you know because there's bad guys and so
we have totally get it yeah yeah we get
it and we have to fill the place in the
bad guys so they don't control that
space
okay we got to fill the space of the bad
guys so they don't control that space
yes that's also big brazinski Harvard's
you know uh straussian uh in justifies
the main stuff this is the really the
philosophy there but but they're really
the bad guys and then about six years
into it my dad came and apologized he
said no you're right and and then and
then and and because the system wasn't
that bad you know on the surface 25
years ago yeah but but then he was no
you're right and like his uh his cousin
you know would do stuff like I'd be over
there for coffee like once or twice a
year and he'd go yeah I've been reading
some of the stuff you're doing you
better be careful they're gonna kill
your ass and I don't even know at that
time that's what he did I mean I'm
sitting there with an army officer that
you know so so let me let me I'm trying
to get the dates right here because so
29 years ago uh makes it uh 1996. is it
is it fair to say you started in 1990s
no no I started in uh 94 94. okay so and
Wikipedia is all wrong 29 years ago
Wikipedia is all wrong it says Infowars
2019 that's just the way the internet
registers it once I transferred it it
started in 1997 I got the website
perfect so 1994 you get started six
years later your dad is saying you're
right is this pre you saying what's
going to happen to the towers or what's
going to happen there's an attack that's
going to happen in July was it pre-dat
event or did your dad say I agree with
what you're doing post that event now he
said he agreed with me right before that
so pre-911 he agreed with you yes and
then what did he say to you after 9 11
when you're like that this is what's
going to happen I'm assuming you're
talking to your mom and dad and like
Alex you sure about this you just made a
that's a pretty outlandish claim you're
making and then boom 911 happens what's
that immediate conversation like with
the re and the reason why I want to
focus on parents is because my influence
is my mom and dad so it's kind of like
there's as you're as you're making these
types of claims unless you say you're on
a crusade I think you in your mind you
think you're on a crusade right that's
right you can't trust a lot of people
there's only a few people you can trust
they can let your guards down and just
talk to them I would assume your mom and
dad are the uh in that oh yeah they were
always good people they weren't villains
and and but my mom you know you know has
you know a degree in history they were
just always into this stuff and they
believed in America and it's like a
naiveness that well we do some bad
things because you know we've gotta you
know uh beat the bad guys so they were
more from the standpoint of Alex you got
a million other things you can do you're
smart why are you doing this this is not
the life you want to live is it kind of
like that message or no uh it was it was
we don't want you to get killed I mean
they they knew they I mean they knew
they're like look you're young and and
yeah the system's bad we you know people
trying to work in it to fix it and you
need to be really I mean it was mainly
you just need to be careful I mean what
was what was the first claim you made
where the first first one where people
are like oh [__] this guy's up to
something what that was kind of weird
what's he talking about what's the first
thing you said that became a reality
that at first everybody fought you on it
because we have this one if you can play
this one here this is July 25th of 2001.
okay whose family builds all the
military
go back there you go I threat like a Bin
Laden who was a known CIA asset in the
80s running the mujahideen war and whose
family builds all the military bases
over in Saudi Arabia right now assistant
the board of iridium satellite
he's the boogeyman they need and the
sorwellian phony system
a big part of the solution after you
research all the government terrorism
and check out what I'm saying is true
call the White House and tell them we
know the government's planning terrorism
we know Oklahoma City and World Trade
Center was terrorism we know the Joint
Chiefs of Staff wanted to blow up
airliners Baltimore Sun if you do it
we're going to blame you because we know
who's up to it or if you let some
terrorist group through it like the
World Trade Center we know who to blame
and if there was an outside threat like
a Bin Laden who was a known CIA asset in
the 80s
so you you say this
pre-it going National and by the way I
did a two and a half hour show that that
be people only have that clip it's in
one of my documentaries I need to find
it and re-upload the web because when
they took me on my YouTube it all got
erased that's a copy of a copy of copy I
did two and a half hours specifically
saying they're going to blow up the
World Trade Center call the White House
tell them don't blow up the World Trade
Center so I'll I'll find that full clip
this week because it needs to go up and
I'll put it back up yeah and by the way
we have your permission to use your
Clips anything you want it's all free so
okay so when you did that what what is
the reaction from that to 910 like pre
or like what are you talking about that
this is going to be happening you you
must be losing your mind like what was
the reaction people gave when he first
said that well it's funny I mean I
already had a local radio show in in uh
2001 and I was I've been fired off local
radio so I was doing it out of my house
but it was actually on a satellite and
on probably 100 stations by then but but
um I this is pre-youtube so if I wanted
to be on TV I'd use the studios a little
access station so that's a two and a
half hour live show I did uh one night
uh you know a few months before 9 11.
and what was the question
no what I'm trying to say is between
this when you make that claim oh I've
got a question I'm a pre-911 during that
two-month period what's the reaction
from people to you and then right after
9 11 happens what do people say about
you sure what happens I was kind of
going back in my memory and then trying
to find exactly that's why I was just
kind of tracing back to the point
because then once I remember one thing I
remember the rest
um this is a crazy story
okay
so I would do live shows once a week
there but we turn a tape in that they'd
air like 10 more times on average so I
shot this live turned the tape in at
Access TV and on the night of 9 11 the
two and a half hour show aired and I got
death threats or anything else because
they thought I was saying that day that
the government had done it when I was
saying July 25th but but later you know
the date came up people figured it out
so people were completely freaked out uh
they didn't know what was going on
um a little bit after this happened they
sent some FBI agents you know in like as
plain clothes to the access station one
night when I was there trying to talk to
me and stuff and ask ask me questions
and hey what do you know about
terrorists do you know anything about
like you know teams or teams of people
and I'm thinking oh you're an FBI agent
I don't know what you mean teams they
were trying to imply like I had Terror
teams or something I guess this struck a
nerve so they sent in a couple FBI
agents uh but and I was on my radio show
we ought to find the archives of that
saying they're going to do it because I
could see the pre-programming
where they're saying terrorists are
about to hit and when the terrorists hit
you've got to give up all your rights
and we're gonna have to have trips on
the streets and blah blah blah and I saw
a couple of globalists uh Gary Hart and
one other guy on
uh
uh CNN and this is right throwing on
there and did this and they and they
were basically saying life's about to
change the world's about to be
completely different
we're gonna have to take your rights
away terrorists are about to hit and I
saw articles in the local paper saying
that I saw the pre-programming like a
rollout was happening and I knew that
islamists had hit the towers
in 1992 it was a real attack but the FBI
had cooked the bomb allowed him to do it
protected him blocked Ahmad Salam the
Egyptian uh is this proven is this it's
all came out yeah and every interview
pull that up go and keep going type in
Ahmad Salam uh uh recordings World Trade
Center bombing
he gave a press conference where he
recorded the FBI tell him no we're gonna
let the bombing go ahead because he
thought they were trying to set him up
and then it did go forward so I already
knew about this I had a lot of data and
a lot of information
feeding into I thought they would go
back and try to bring down the World
Trade Center a second time because in
criminology that's what happens and they
did have people on airplanes and they
were Islam assist but it turns out they
were CIA with double passports and we're
being protected and they thought they
were taking part in a hijacking drill
that day and then what really happened
is they nerve gassed the people on the
planes from the best info we have then
remote control them into the towers and
then another one was supposed to hit the
Pentagon uh but uh uh people despite the
fact that they have the stewardess
recordings where they're saying I can't
breathe I can't breathe there's gas
that's what's really happening again but
before they could do that uh a F-16 uh
put and that's in the FAA recordings put
two aim9s into it and shot it down uh
over Pennsylvania
yeah I was in the United States Air
Force while all that was happening and I
was on the on the on a shooting team and
two days before the competition one of
my sergeants and I'm not going to say
his name was like hey well Shawna
because I was the best shooter Alex he's
like the competition's canceled and I
was like what are you hot why 9 11
happens and then we were warned rump
still went on went in front of the White
House and he was like Uh something's
happening where terrorism he kind of
warned us Condoleezza Rice warned the
mayor of was it Chicago don't fly to New
York this day and then you nailed it
Alex when you were talking about Osama
Bin Laden every flight in the entire
United States was grounded there was a
couple f-16s circling the only
commercial flights that were left from
here flew to Ramstein Germany and those
Osama Bin Laden's entire family they
flew them all out that was on local
Miami News
but it gets worse what I'm saying
there's thousands of pieces of data
they didn't find one they found two
hijackers passports unburned in that
whole explosion so you got 10 feet of
dust everywhere billions of papers but
those get found the next day you believe
that so so and it goes on for days
but I interviewed
the former chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff right before he died about this
and a bunch of other people and they
they told me before it came out a few
years later that all the top generals
were supposed to go to New York that day
for a big meeting they got told not to
go and remember
um uh the the Pentagon asked infant
guard leaders a month for about two
weeks before he pulls up articles that's
all that corporate Executives you know
getting get approached be part of
Homeland Security before they announced
that name and infrastructure protection
and the whole Shadow government program
they flew him to Offutt Air Force Base
um was that the one that's just remember
it's just ancient history they flew them
all to an Air Force Base and hadn't been
a hangar when the attack was happening
and closed the doors and gave him some
secret briefing look up uh uh Business
Leaders billionaires uh flown to Air
Force Base in 911 it's it's all up there
and this is such ancient history having
gone over this in years I should write a
book on 9 11 and go back over it all I
mean it is just insane if you can break
down all the conspiracy theories
regarding 911 true false this that the
other and if you can break it down to
the lowest common denominator of who was
involved the motivation what actually
happened what transpired more than meets
the eye how would you break that down in
as few words as possible
well what we have is perception
management going on and so the submarine
thing the Titan and the Titanic all of
this is a is a great window into this I
don't know what really happened there we
know we're being lied to we know the um
Navy and the Coast Guard have incredible
sonar that area in the Atlantic's
heavily covered because there's nuclear
submarine stuff and they know the
signature of an imploding vessel it's
been studied heavily and they also know
the sound of it hitting the bottom I
mean they can hear somebody thumping on
the side of a submarine of 3000 miles
away and they've got signatures this is
the there's there's been hundreds of
billions of dollars put into the to
These acoustic sonar systems other
things and they've got even more
advanced stuff like that that deals with
these giant antennas they've got strung
out that are sending waves to the Earth
it's beyond sonar to pick all this stuff
up it's just it's insane and so they
knew exactly when it imploded they knew
they were dead they they knew about the
wreckage and they and the commander said
we reported it it's not our job talk to
media and they decided not to tell you
yeah and so they just decided to leave
it out there there's a distraction with
all the 100 Biden stuff coming out just
like they indicted Trump Jack Smith did
the day the last big trunch of Hunter
Biden stuff came out so don't let a good
crisis go to waste were they in the
submarine they really die I mean we get
lied to so much who knows and am I going
to get sued for seven point or 2.75
trillion I mean all I know is I'm saying
I've been lied to so much I don't know
but I know this
my phone blew up my text messages I've
never been asked in a short period of
time so many times since since Monday
what do you think really happened
uh with the submarine and that shows
people don't buy it and almost everybody
says I don't think anybody was on it or
I think they knew they were already dead
I was hearing this on Monday and oh
they're already dead they know they're
dead they're just gonna have this like
the boy in the well and so everybody
focuses on it and I'm like I don't know
so I didn't comment until Friday because
what I've learned is they spin when I
just question and wargame something and
then say look he says nobody died and
they'll go to the Widow one of the
submarine guys go look he's up there
making money saying nobody died and then
they'll then they'll I mean literally
that's that's the model but what's
happening is the public doesn't believe
any of it almost no one I talk to like
No One Believes it so
you ask your question is you know what's
the biggest thing we expose or how does
this mind control work I think we're
coming out of it we have a discredited
corporate media we have a discredited uh
government that's been hijacked the
Public's really you know ending their
naivete and figuring out they've been
lied to and beginning the Journey of
discovering what's happening I think
popular podcasts and shows like yours uh
that are really I think middle of the
road but are actually just looking at
the facts are going to lead the way out
of this as the New Media is now the
mainstream media I mean you know your
show's bigger than most the shows on
cable Joe Rogan's show I think something
like 50 times bigger than a CNN show uh
you know 15 times bigger than a fox show
and but but why do we still call it the
mainstream media why do we still sit all
they are is disruptors that sit there
and use psychological warfare to
manipulate us and so it's very healthy
that people don't believe anything
they're told that's your right
especially when you've been lied to so
much if I had a neighbor that lied to me
once I think they were weird they lied
to me twice I'm not going to talk to
them anymore at least people have been
lying to us caught and then laugh about
it how funny it is I mean take James
O'Keefe last year
about a year and a half ago this is a
full year before they totally shut it
down
well we're going to end the whole
covered thing and stop hyping that for
now and we're going to be all global
warming and lockdowns and energy
shortages and collapsing stuff and you
know you know just the end of
civilization into the world and then
like a light switch they a few months
later all the media on the same day gets
the new script to shift to that well
that's the dinosaur media and the only
Power they have is getting us to kind of
debate what they're saying and doing
when at a certain point you realize it's
just all crap and that's happened the
average CNN show has like 80 000 viewers
uh the the the fox has lost half their
viewers at least they're down from an
average of two million viewers like less
than a million they're all committing
suicide you see Anheuser-Busch
committing suicide uh but then uh Modelo
smart we want to celebrate Sports Heroes
and icons and War veterans and families
and Heritage and and then and then like
it's not just Hispanics going on buying
the Beards the white people they go yeah
we want to celebrate Heritage too I mean
we just we want to crack a beer and
think about you know our country and our
mothers and fathers and sisters and
brothers and children now we're good
people and how we want to be successful
we want to hear about a boxer or a
swimmer or a firefighter that save kids
we don't want to see some clown hop
around the dress and we're sick of the
demoralization so they're attempted to
moralize us is not demoralizing us now
it's causing the Great Awakening so so
you know uh when you're saying that
here's how I process it so take somebody
that's watching this and saying I cannot
believe these guys are hosting Alex
Jones this guy is the platform from
everywhere Twitter even Elon Musk
doesn't have Alex Jones which will I
want to ask you about that as well and
wait a minute but so so so there are the
people that 100 agree with you they're
loving what you're saying look oh this
is awesome great keep going it and then
there's the people in the middle like
yeah kind of let me you know kind of
makes sense and the people on the one
side that you're not going to win
anyways I just want to talk to the
people in the middle forget about either
side I want to talk to the people in the
middle
so if you're like me as a middle eastern
Alex I'm naturally super skeptical I'm a
paranoid guy I don't trust a lot of
people okay I'm kind of like well what's
the guy's motive
etc etc but here's the part Rob we've
shown this before here's Publix trust in
the U.S government from 58 to today it's
the lowest it's been look at the numbers
right there I mean I've I think the
lowest it hit was under Obama if you
look at it there in and out
from there kept going kept going kept
going it hasn't increased now go to the
public trust in mainstream media which
is even worse we were all the way up at
you know 75 percent in 1976 give or take
and it has gradually declined all the
way down to 34 so it's not and by the
way I've looked at these big National
polls they're still sampling more
Mainline people so from the numbers I've
seen and what they internally have they
can do with these algorithms it's way
worse Congress is more like five percent
and the mean trust in Congress yes and
you pull that up and the media is nine
and by the way these numbers are from
Gallup these it's not exactly some
random
Gallop though is is is is is is is from
what we've seen is is it's worse than
what's what they're saying but here's
the part though even with Gallup for
Gallup to show seven I mean seven
percent Americans have common or
Industries failing us okay so so what's
the key word there that we're not
trusting institutions
establishment okay like people are
wondering and nowadays even college
education is it even worth for me to go
to college what am I going to go to
college for and that's why they want to
watch a new show check what it's saying
and then they basically Knight that as
the new show like yours or Joe Rogan
because because they trust you does that
make sense yeah so so they've committed
suicide and they think destroying us
will make them be risen from the dead
they could take us all out new people
will pop right back I think I think what
people want is to listen to other
skeptical people I think Joe's skeptical
I don't look at Joe and I'm like you
know Joe is a you know a guy that's
fully trying to push an agenda I think
Joe Sanderson guys I don't know what's
going on here I'm going through the
product like the way you opened up
skeptical and he is curious I love the
way he's very curious I love the way he
opened up the RFK interview where he
said I'm not going to lie to you for the
last five years you know when I would
watch sometimes this guy's a cook this
guy's this I'm like okay probably not
and then all of a sudden I'm like wait a
minute some of the stuff he's saying is
true and then I read the book and I'm
like holy [__] and then we ran into each
other at the it's funny the same
restaurant we were at it was myself him
and RFK Casa D'Angelo and we have to
give a shout out to Casa D'Angelo Aspen
we were just a day apart
so so that's how they connected like hey
I want to get you on the podcast and
then obviously when he did the podcast
he pissed off everybody Dr hottest all
these things anyways what I do want to
do is this before we go into the next
one Rob can you pull up the next thing
here with the the Tucker Carlson video
he had uh I want to say it's in March or
something like that when you said this
uh again this was a couple months before
it happened uh rob you had it uh just a
minute ago you had it so and it's like
how hotels won't debate look at Kirby
and all of them running off the stage
they're running they're they're running
that's when you're fleeing that's when
you've been routed in a war yeah but but
folks like Maddie assana are saying he
shouldn't debate you know Time Magazine
he shouldn't debate they said no he said
he said in science we don't debate yeah
exactly
so I'm saying in boxing we don't we
don't fight yeah so play this clip this
this is when Rob can you can you first
show today this is March of this year
right we're talking March of this year
March 8th of this year this is you okay
if you can play this
he gets what's going on he's not going
back he is he believes in the people and
so
I predict he won't be at Fox News the
near future if he's unable to put this
out
I'm gonna leave it at that but that's
speaking from my perspective I'm not
speaking for Tucker well Cheryl Atkinson
for saying that why just say Tucker's
not going to be at Fox long obviously
two months later he's not and there's
there's a feud there but why why did you
say that well because they'll attribute
things to Tucker because they know we
talk some and hang out some uh you know
he's on the other side of Florida over
in uh Naples Minnesota Boca Grande or
whatever uh and so we hung out on
Thanksgiving last year but uh he he used
to think I was full of it and then he
kind of woke up with a lot of stuff came
in to visit me like 10 11 12 years ago
we came friends hung out and then he
still thought it was kind of crazy and
then he learned more and more as it went
along uh and so I had called him I think
we talked like the day before that or
something I don't remember exactly and
I'd said listen
all the things you're doing uh are
they're gonna let you go there's no way
that and we had a proper conversation
about that and he didn't see it coming
and I said I said well I just really
think you should do Your Own Thing uh
when this goes down and I said uh
because we'd already talked about this
summer Thanksgiving uh and the
infrastructure independent things the
future and because he's kind of sticking
his toe in that and
then I said okay well I predict you're
going to be gone within a month I said I
I smell it and I just it's not even like
being psychic I get all this data and
all I do is immerse myself he called the
Holy Spirit whatever you want but it's
like boom then I see something like I
saw the World Trade Center towers on
fire I saw I saw all the troops in the
streets and I could just see all the
programming because because you could
just see how they're getting you ready
for it and like you said when you're in
the military they start telling you hey
terrorism is about to happen get ready
boys yeah get ready boys well they were
doing that I mean like get ready the
terrorists are about to hit us and your
life's Gonna Change it's not that hard
okay what are they going to hit what are
they programming and then they they just
had a lone gunman show uh where they
flew a uh jumbo jet hijacked into the
World Trade Center to blame uh a middle
eastern terrorist to invade Afghanistan
now I said
at the time I said see they're going to
attack the World Trade Center that's
another reason later Chris Carter
contacts me and says yes that's true the
CIA contacted me they did this routinely
and they basically wrote that script
nine months before 9 11 and then he
produces it
either six months before it was a loan
government spin-off and then he based
the 2016 series on me that's the
interview he said that I'm trying to
practice it's crazy the whole talk shows
ends up being right at the end and uh
and that's another reason they came
after me because they're like this guy's
getting too popular even with the
Thinker people they don't control so the
CI came to Carter and said we want you
to put this out
um and then you notice it's 2016 show is
all about a uh vaccine that has a system
in it that basically destroys your
immune system
and so they have some recent one to
pre-program us and I don't think
Carter's with him I think he figured out
he thought he was just helping he
realizes now he was like programming the
subconscious for something this is very
sophisticated you have your conscious
you have your unconscious and you have
your uh subconscious uh or or you have
your your conscience and you have your
subconscious and you have the
unconscious and so they're they're
directly trying to talk to the
unconscious and that's thousands of
times more powerful they believed in the
conscious and hundreds of times more
than the unconscious why do you think
they let Tucker go why do you think
specifically on the fox say well
actually no why okay I mean well they
were already planning to do it and then
um
let's just say this the Vanity Fair
article or the was The Hollywood
Reporter I forget which one was the one
that Rupert Murdoch was upset by his
fiancee being Christian
oh yeah I remember reading that word
talk because Tucker was talking about
God a lot in that speech and that it
pissed him off because Rupert is an
atheist well and they're not really
pissed off Vanity Fair well Jennifer and
so and so the night the night uh he they
they pulled the trigger was when he gave
that Heritage Foundation speech he said
look God's real you need to pray to God
at least five minutes a day Evil's real
uh and you need to get God you need to
get God right now Tucker said that
Tucker did that later speech yeah at the
Heritage Foundation and then Murdoch
called the uh the head of fox and said I
want him fired and I want him fired
Monday morning don't tell him until uh
we put the press release out
simultaneously so they call him get him
on the phone say you're fired and then
put the press release out hang up on
Alex how do you know this and then they
won't tell him how do you know this is
it because people from I can't give
swords I'm not giving no I'm not giving
names I'm not giving names okay my
sources are so good that I even I
haven't had Tucker's guy was like come
on Alex don't tell everybody everything
and I didn't even get it from Tucker I
got some of it the point is I know
everything okay somebody in fact I got
stuff so incredible to blow you away but
I can't tell you it's pretty amazing
this is all like from my perspective
this is what I hear what I'm getting is
I have a different Source my source is
the amount of people that have reached
out out that want to come join our
organization and we're not even a big
Media Company we're barely getting
started we're a small little Media
company here in South Florida and
would've been but the amount of people
that are saying hey are you looking for
talent we heard you're looking for
talent uh we don't want to be here long
term some of the stuff that's going on
the inside at Fox is not something oh
Fox is falling apart I mean Tucker
obviously is former lead producer that
put the thing that bidens an aspiring
dictator that was his last hurray
knowing they'd fire him he's going
they're all going to join Tucker he's
built it
no no that's all I'm saying is we get
the column P so you're saying Tucker's
planning on building a media company
or on Twitter I think that's obvious
okay
I mean yes but here's the thing I don't
want to give anything out of confidence
and so I've learned Fox sources have
other sources I've talked to people and
I mean that's obvious that's what he's
going to do I mean in his first new show
that got like 100 whatever million views
he said I plan to do monologues and then
more things after that so yes what you
saw with this Fox Nation thing but Done
Right is what he's planning that's all
the thing is people say things are
classified of their secret real
intelligence is what's right in front of
you so Tucker has said he's going to do
all this and so then I do know some of
the things he's planning but I'm not
going to repeat that I can just tell you
what I can with human intelligencies
going on but but yes Fox is has fox has
actually lost 50 plus percent of its
main viewers uh it's like 65 of their
key demo uh basically they committed
suicide again just like all these other
leftist companies uh because they're
planning something big and I don't think
they care the central banks with the
esgs to give them unlimited money to
prop them up later that's why these
companies fall over themselves to lose
24 billion at Target or you know 15
billion in Anheuser-Busch fall over
themselves to do this is because they're
planning something so big and things are
going to be shook up so bad that none of
this is going to be here anymore and
then that leads us to the Russian
situation who who are some of the guys
you're seeing right now that are either
in the process of being the next Tuckers
or are in the camp of uh Tucker that
they're pushing the envelope they're
challengedy they're challenging The
Establishment who else would you put
obviously not a Tucker's level Tucker's
a guy that's the MJ the industry today
who else you see is coming up whatever
different places they are are there any
other names that you're seeing that's
going under the direction that Tucker's
gone like for example when we used to
watch Tucker back in the days with
Crossfire and he's doing what he's doing
with Jon Stewart and Jon Stewart's
trying to punk him and you see how
Tucker stood up to him you know and and
challenge him and then look he went from
being who he was back then and the bow
tie to not being the Tucker of nobody's
getting the kind of eyeballs he's
getting so who won at the end of the day
Tucker won from going uh uh you know
Tucker is a genuinely nice guy but he's
also a big guy and really smart and he
has member so the point is is that them
messing with him and stuff made him go
from being a Mr Nice Guy to know More Mr
Nice Guy and now he's really No More Mr
Nice Guy uh so uh yeah I don't think
anybody's in his class for being able to
do interviews or think on his feet or do
a great monologue because he writes all
that himself he's a great writer great
researcher and then I think Joe Rogan
just because his curiosity and because
of his uh you know being skeptical
obviously he's just going to continue to
get bigger
um I mean I think uh you know people
like yourself I mean I would think I
mean I've seen your show exponentially
grow it's always been popular but I see
it everywhere now it's obviously
exploding
um what do you think about I guess the
question I was more asking is guys from
mainstream media not not the podcast
guys like who at Fox do you see do you
do you do you like what Brett does do
you like what you know uh uh some of the
guys at uh
oh oh you know Megan Kelly's doing
obviously Megan Kelly's at a different
place who are some of the names that
you're saying and Megan's already she's
won the best I'm talking about some of
the people at fox say you're saying that
guy maybe won't be at Fox too long
himself is there anyone at Fox that
you're thinking your question
um
no I don't think anybody's in Tucker's
League I don't think any of those those
people all just have producers
we try to break stories they try to
chase stories and fox is basically a
sinking ship and so I do think a lot of
them are going to leave and be
successful and whatever type of programs
they do but at the same time look
everything is going to be either you're
a populist anti-new world order or
you're a globalist suck-up and so that's
it everything's going to go towards you
know are you going to sit there and buy
the BS of Niels deGrasse Tyson when he
just tells you stuff that's completely
untrue and he just says science science
you're like well show me science and so
he's like you know I have a pink
Lamborghini outside well show me no
science you don't question that you know
I say it's gonna be 400 degrees outside
tomorrow well show me the facts no
science well it was all tested all the
these drugs were all approved no they
weren't they were brought on market and
then approved an emergency deal that's
totally separate never before done he
says no it was all approved massive
testing we've never done more studying
in our entire universe as we've done on
these shots these are safe effective
Pure Clean wonderful and not one word if
that's true
I mean remember the first year it was an
open piece of paper when you opened up
the vaccine ampule by law that's being
there and it just said the name of the
company not one thing that was in it
because it was none of it was approved
emergency authorization and then they
did quote studies and suppress those
studies and that's all a fact and they
don't want you to even be able to say
that anybody can look at what I just
said so it's going to be are you going
to sit there and take the establishments
money and tell people
uh that there's you know that that that
there's ice water in Hell or are you
going to try to figure out what's going
on so everything is going to be the
Quest for legitimacy the quest uh for
curiosity and the quest of skepticism
and if you're not skeptical in this
environment you're an idiot we have
gotten in this situation because we've
not been skeptical and if you go to
places like Russia or the Middle East or
places that have had the turmoil more
recently people are skeptical or they're
dead and so you either get skeptical and
get your head in the game and learn how
stuff works or you're dead we've had it
so good in this country
we're the best house in a bad
neighborhood we've had it so good in
this country for at least 150 years okay
and this place has been a Wonderland
compared to most other countries and so
people now have grown up off our
grandparents off their grandparents the
average American and have no idea how
good we've had it and the fact that God
is lowering the defense shield now
because we have stopped you know being
good moral people and now tyranny's
flooding in and we better find God and
find skepticism and find rugged
individualism and find the will to stand
up and have courage or we'll lose
everything people always say oh you've
got courage to fight them
I'm trying to get out of like walls
closing in on my family and my country
in the world it's not courage to be
trying to get out of this thing I mean
you take the cheesy Star Wars analogy
where they're the trash compactor is
going to kill them do they have courage
trying to go there no they're fighting
for their lives if somebody tied bowling
balls in my legs and threw me in the
deep end and I'm fighting trying to claw
my way up out of there it's not courage
it's the opposite it's self-preservation
so people better understand it's not
courage okay it's the courage to save
yourself which isn't courage at all in
my view so Alex uh it's obviously a
pattern when it comes to people that are
exposing the truth the elites and
everything you Julian Assange Edward
Snowden Andrew Tay RFK people like even
me personally is there a light at the
end of the tunnel like is are is there a
chance for us to win or are we fighting
a losing battle because Alex they have
set up the pieces to this game that
we're playing in is there a light like
with people like this that you have this
passion the truth is coming out but is
it all for nothing there is a lot of tea
on the tunnel
uh you know they they've gone and dug up
those temples of Ramses II 3 000 plus
years ago uh more than that with with
Moses so what you see in the Ten
Commandments I mean that was real people
real stuff went on people can question
the so you know the the biblical story
they want but you know Moses existed
Ramsey's the second existed all that
went on you're saying what's that do
with what I asked
the Israelites had to stop doing what
they were told caused everybody's seen
that Meme that shows like five burn
matches and then one match and it says
uh you know non-compliance or yeah
non-conformity and then all the other
matches aren't burned you can stop the
chain reaction and so finally after you
know decades or whatever it was of the
Jews saying we're done being your slaves
they said okay pack your stuff up and go
okay and the desert was rough and it was
tough and they went through a lot of
hell then they built their own thing and
so look how you built Your Own Thing The
Establishment became corrupt the
mainstream media lie does it committed
it committed suicide now we're building
a new system the Amish 400 years ago
were Protestants they were being
persecuted in Switzerland and Germany so
they packed up sold everything and moved
here and still today they don't have
autism they don't have any other stuff
they don't have suicide rates they're
living the dream because they don't hang
out with big Pharma and and so we don't
have to do what the Amish have done but
we have to be in the world but not of
the world to use the Christian allegory
and we have to build our own systems
build our own companies instead of a
boycott which is great against
anheuser-buscher Target we need a
boycott and when we start you and that's
what esgs are is they've they've
analyzed all this they know the boycott
by populous by Christians by
conservatives by people just want to be
capitalists and live normal and be able
to defend ourselves and create wealth we
can do anything we want humans are
incredible instead of being ruled by
these globalists on this porch so they
can dictate the terms of our surrender
we have to build the New Renaissance we
have to build the Great Awakening it has
to be a spiritual awakening in God in
Christ and we have to call on God
because they've got their god notice
Target like literally put out shirts
with an artist that says
in the devil yeah we are Satanist and we
are going to recruit your kids and an
adult shirt with that a shirt the the
designers it was all devil worship
sayings he Satan loves trans s for Satan
now they threw that that's in there
Robert says Target right there go right
there top left Target and uh that's that
was the pin that they were selling
Target respects Satan respects
pronounselves 100 there was something we
sent crew and got a video of it that
they were selling they were selling this
in our sorry to get ignite's Firestorm
would launch of new clothing line
designed by Satan 100 dismissable as I
buy mile and then some can you zoom in a
little bit the retail giant has been
selected by a few brands of the United
Kingdom that promotes Satan you read it
right targets Partners
uh it has producer a prayer collection
for targets a celebration of LGBT pride
month and promotes satanic images themes
go to Twitter and the woman has an
account these are shirts not just Arts
witches for what they are they also
offer clothing and accessories that
includes catchphrases like trans witches
for abortions Okay click on that and
let's try to buy it go to transwitches
well here's the good news they pulled it
after a week okay yeah but they got and
then they got all these bomb threats
from the LGBT pieces yes leave it in
there the the rainbow Mafia the Rancho
Mafia was like yo we're gonna bomb
Target if you try to mess with it go on
that Etsy page go on that Etsy page uh
yeah that one right there because that
guy that guy's name Abra Allen whatever
his name is Witch is for abortion listen
they actually sold the shirts that had a
guillotine and said and said and said
we're going to kill homophobes yeah and
then and then it shows an adult skeleton
giving a baby skeleton the trans fire
and it says we will recruit your
children they will be trans
if you want to pull out the story so and
now it's like I'll give a couple
examples before we talk about Boston I'm
talking about let's
talked about this yesterday so when
people say when people like you when
people like me talk about this attack on
children this satanic going after
children and and the trans movement just
a couple of quick stories that happened
this week in Boston four kids were found
in a drag party with one dead trans guy
on the floor and the kids were in the
back there were sex toys scattered
throughout the house and a hoarder home
doesn't make headline news but the
that's the and they were the
firefighters said they were hiding the
kids in the back bedroom they were
hiding the Daily Mail right here put it
out there yeah so this is not so this is
not a right-wing Source yeah Daily Mail
and yeah and let's keep the stories
going the first Trans State
Representative Stacy Lawton AKA Barry
Lawton from New Hampshire was just
arrested for Distributing child porn
okay it just happened and mind you they
couldn't find them because he
transitioned and changed his name how
about this one by the way they're trying
to pass laws in in California and other
states where once you change your name
if you're trans sponges your your your
criminal records yeah so just change
your name Alex yeah so yeah now you're
Alexandra Jones exonerated
no money and one more so three days ago
the xcnn producer John Griffin was
sentenced 19 years for sexually
assaulting a nine-year-old okay and then
this was the other day this is in New
York City a drag March where the
Marchers are chanting we're here we're
queer we're here for your children tell
me this isn't disgusting
[Music]
now listen this is how
much
how do you want to bet those Republic
School teachers
did you see the San Francisco city
funded uh uh gay choir where they go
we're coming for your children we'll
take them you'll love it and then we'll
get you to we're gonna get your children
and then they go to the city councils
all over even the conservative areas and
go we are going to recruit your children
and have sex with them
Rob do you can you pull that up and
Alice how was that not the headline
story but the Titanic sinking ship with
five people is the number one story oh
yeah and Blue's Clues now awesome right
here on mainstream TV has bathamet and
moloch and the kids being sacrificed oh
my God yeah so this this is this is
exactly but here's what's happening let
me tell you what I think is happening
and I and I kind of agree with what
you're saying I think Common Sense will
prevail and a lot of people are sitting
there saying this just doesn't make any
sense you saw the Gallup poll that came
back where America is right right now
with the lgbtq and and where they're
standing how the biggest plus minus was
the fact that the American people are no
longer as comfortable as they were
dropped by seven percent year over year
where we're at and the the even the
Glendale stuff that's going on with the
kids the parents coming out saying this
is too much across on the line more and
more people are being united on esg's
Bad Idea more and more people are being
united with you can't be grooming our
kids more and more people are stunned to
realize this is not just what we're all
about and it's not just the people from
the right it's it's people from who have
historically voted Democrat that are
saying look man I don't know what the
hell is going on this isn't what I
supported it's a lunatic asylum yeah
you're seeing you're seeing it's going
from Democrat versus Republican where
it's going from establishment against
anti-establishment that's the two
political parties we're gradually going
away from the Republican and the
Democratic party we're going to the
anti-establishment and the establishment
party if you yeah you know what I don't
trust these establishment anymore like I
used to I just don't it also goes to a
ridiculous versus just common sense
stuff like this
we're coming for your children and how
Patrick that that is listen to me that's
the devil out in the open they're not
even hiding and they're saying this
towards the end they say we're going to
get them we're going to groom them
they're ours they're gonna love it so
will you this transcends party lines
this is
a bunch of them were registered sex
offenders with children these guys yeah
I'm a bunch of them
the majority what are they say in this
video what are they say I don't know
this was a city-sponsored choir I mean
it's nauseating but just click on it
last third from 2021 okay
for your chair
foreign
[Music]
sang a song about coming for your
children it was like they spelled the
plan out in plain like Alex said
sometimes just look right in front of
your face what they're saying it doesn't
need to be conspiratorial they're
[__] say it yeah there's no hiding
can we continue the song was that just
the point of the song yeah sing along if
you know the words out there
unbelievable we're coming for your
children Helen and they're doing it it's
worse letter like we will groom them and
we're gonna get you to you belong to us
your body is ours and America left wants
to make you take the shots too it's all
about rape rape and Alex
you warned about the Epstein Island
situation way before he got arrested way
before he committed suicide what like
I mean here's an example I I was
um I I got put like 20 years ago in some
Hollywood movies never even asked to do
it Rick and clutter is a great guy not
part of Hollywood and he barely put me
in um uh waking live at the scanner
darkly with Keanu Reeves and people and
but I also consulted on those on
professional Scanner Darkly so then
that's how I got into Hollywood Martin
Sheen uh saw one of my anti-war films
and said I'd like you to fly out to
California so this is like this is like
a 2004 or something Charlie Sheen's dead
yeah yeah so that's how I met Charlie
Sheen so I'm at their house in Malibu
and that'd be a party and they're there
and there's like you know all of a
sudden uh Anthony Hopkins comes over and
it's like I'm sitting at their house and
they're they're watching one of my
documentaries tell me how great I am so
I think I'm a leftist because it's
anti-war which I am anti-war says it is
a populist as a conservative as a person
and then Emilio Estevez comes over and
then also Charlie Sheen comes over and
goes hey man I'll fly out here next time
once you get Bob on back then he was
with um he was off the drugs that he was
smoking cigarettes he was with uh the
dark the hot girl that was the girl
before that who's the one that's in
Starship troops oh Denise Richards
that's what he was married to as kids
with yeah yeah so I'm used to go stay in
his house his kids are there you're
staying with Charlie Sheen oh yeah yeah
buddy invite me to the party next time
Alex well no I've stayed with him when
he went downhill
he used to like hey my house is always
here man and listen you can use all my
cars here and here drop my Porsche it's
like 800 horsepower first gear that was
like 60 miles an hour yeah because I was
like I I I and I've driven sticking good
but I had to like turn it around and
bring it back to his house he said hey
man I want some Taco Bell he could take
the portion he'll get me some down the
hill seriously and I'm like I didn't
bring my God can I drive another car go
back to what was happening go back so
this part Charlie
look at these guys oh I mean you look
you look like you were you were in good
shape he looks like he was he was rough
right there tiger blood so as you were
saying about the value so
um yeah and so then I got to know all
these other people yeah those were
off-record stuff but I mean like he he
had to go to dinner with Buzz Alder and
buzzer all about the aliens and the
secret bases and the Obelisk and how
they're gonna find water in two years
we're gonna let the Indians find it and
two years later I'm in a I'm in an
airport and there's a newspaper saying
and I mean just the most wacky stuff so
so then I start doing all these other
holiday people because I was going on TV
shows and like some some reality shows
about conspiracy did a whole bunch of
them five or six of them I probably
weren't mad and so I was on on a lot of
TV programs I was doing voiceovers doing
real well
and then I just this is probably like
16 years ago or so I knew some folks
they go listen you think Hollywood's
cool he goes this wasn't Charlie some
other people they go they go there's
like three groups which is people that
are here that make the money and then
you try to live outside the area and
then they're scientologists and then
there really is like a cult CIA devil
worshipers and I didn't run this from
Martin Sheen or Charlie Sheen for other
people and it was like yeah they've got
these Cults but they all feed into this
larger CIA group and they brand the
women on their bellies and all and that
was Nexium and then they've got these
islands where they get these politicians
and scientists and people to compromise
them and it's all run by MI6 CIA Mossad
and they fly them out to these islands
and he goes they're not just having sex
with kids he goes they also that's the
entry door and I learned this from more
people in it and found it from other
folks and then I talked to entertainers
and then I talked to well-known
musicians and like that's why a lot of
them just leave because
um this happened to Mark Dice who's you
know been friends with forever he got
offered a major show
by the largest uh reality TV show group
and this is like 10 years ago now and
they get him in there at the end of it
and they say well here's the last thing
we want you they're a huge show with a
huge
um with one of the Motley Crew guys it
was Nikki Sixx and the head of the
company goes but we want you to pledge
yourself to Lucifer and Mark said well
I'm a Christian to go well we know you
say you are but let's just get this out
of the way and he says is this a joke
they said no I'm deadly serious with you
now that's just one guy that will go
public I I got told that and and I've
and I've had a lot of meetings I have
meetings with Bilderberg Group members
I've had meetings with all these folks
and they're off record me so I never
talk about them but one time
the head of the Kissinger group rothkop
in front of my producer said we want you
to come work for us we want you to come
to New York next week we're gonna you
know there's only a few thousand people
in the super class we want you to lead
uh you know basically the the populist
Liberty Movement but you're gonna see at
the table but you'll have to do what we
tell you but you'll get some you'll
you'll get to have some input you can be
on your Crusade and fail or you can join
us so that was offered in front of John
harm my producer I said this off
regularly said no just join us but that
wasn't Satanism
the way they said it there but it's
always the same speech and and so I have
repeatedly uh had people one time I had
this major executive trying to give me a
10 million year contract and multiple
multi-book deals every year and they
said you just got to come in and do the
show but we'll control what we do and
I'm sitting there and this guy's wife
comes in and we're up at this big
high-rise you know uh
corporate office and This Woman's super
beautiful and they go I hear you like to
have fun you want to have sex with my
wife right now she thinks you're hot she
wants to have sex what do I need to do
they need to get on my knees and have
you sign this contract then another time
they offer you this deal absolutely
another time they sent this famous CIA
guy same deal I I meet with him all the
stuff he gets on his knees
so and that's what these people do
because they want that baseball card
they want to own Alex Jones and they're
going to want to own you and when you
get popular and they're going to want
and they're super crazy stuff like like
I'd already heard about this when I was
talking to a very well-known individual
I can't tell the whole story but
he was being flown by the same guy that
was flying the king of a major Middle
Eastern country and I'm not going to say
this we don't get the guy in trouble
this is on a big jump big jet jumbo
large full body Jet and this is this is
the chief pilot and he tells this guy
that I know doesn't BS he tells them
listen I've only done this you're like
once had said all these ndas all this
other stuff we get on the jumbo jet with
the with the king of this major deal and
it's and and there's other Jets a couple
Jets following with his family because
that's how they do it
and he says go to these coordinates and
he wouldn't even say what ocean but he
goes there's nothing there and he goes
no go there they go there it's a private
island Beyond it's like seven star if
such a thing existed and no homeless
nothing nothing but billionaires but
it's it's just everything and and
telling you that's the level of this
control and I guarantee you they've
approached Joe Rogan because he's I'm
not gonna he hasn't told me but I could
tell uh you know I'm in the last year
he's gotten the talking to him but he
said screw him I could tell uh we hang
out and have dinner and talk some of the
point is I can just tell because I know
people get these speeches and uh sure is
there another Epstein Island but well
that's the level the level of yes
absolutely when you say an island yeah I
mean I'm being told by well-known people
that man hey you think Hollywood's cool
you know what are you going to do when
you're at a party some night
and they bring a 16 year old girl in
there and start having sex with her and
just implicate you're in the building
wow and that's why you need to not go to
that party tonight you need to get out
of here okay that's the kind of stuff
really prominent people you know you're
like telling you this place is dangerous
and you need to watch out because I was
getting deep into Hollywood I mean I was
I was at parties with the biggest names
but I mean you just have to think about
if if uh Rob what is this you pulled up
here this nxivm that's the sex cult that
Alex was talking about in Los Angeles
name of commonly used to describe the
personality Cult of imprisoned racketeer
and sex offender Keith Rainier is also
trademark named defunct corporation that
Ranier founded which provided seminars
and videos in the field of human
potential development in the United
States seized ownership of the
organizational related entities and
personal Intel intellectual property
through asset forfeiture allowing
Revenue to con
us
[Music]
but that's just one feeder group that's
just one feeder group
so they have all these little you know
kind of like the Hell's Angels or the
Mongols will have a sub motorcycle gang
that's not members but works for them
yeah and then and then they all have
guys under them
and so that's how they work so
But but so I was told by a lot of people
that this stuff was going on and the and
that and that Hollywood was run by
basically I mean if you've seen that new
movie I forget the name of it it was
pretty powerful it's actually somewhat
historic it's a composite
um Babylon about Hollywood
uh that the latest movie that just came
out it was a movie or documentary the
freedom no I think it was called Babylon
Hollywood Babylon got to find that room
it just came out I watched it like what
was the problem is it in theaters
it was in theaters
it was a big movie what was the what was
the premise of the movie it was the
early days of Hollywood in the uh in the
20s and 30s
um
Hollywood yeah I see it right here right
there Hollywood Babylon
yeah
click it
I think we were black comments Margot
Robbie
Brad Pitt
anyways you watch that that's that stuff
went on go to the poster on the right or
the poster right there punch in
is that it yeah and so this is based on
Pitt Margot Robbie Babylon what's this
based on real like the Patriot Mel
Gibson was a composite of three stories
but they're true and and that's the same
thing for a lot of these movies but but
I read the research on this this is a
composite of real stuff that went on in
Hollywood so this devil worship
cannibalism uh eating rats uh while you
know all having sex with hot women
because to them it's not enough to have
a hot woman now you need to have it Brad
Pitt is in it Michael Robbie's on it
yeah
why would they make a movie trashing
their own industry
I think they think it's cool and uh is
is it coming from a place of like
exposing the truth or is it coming from
a place of this is the level you make it
if you become very famous they basically
say this is Hollywood's Tombstone the
movie and and
they just say this is who we are and
Hollywood's dead now so now here's the
story of how we began and that maybe
we'll be reborn somewhere else it's
pretty strange right there because we're
all in the phase now of even the system
has to expose itself now because this is
the season of that and and so but I'm
telling you watch this movie this is
devil worship in the 20s and 30s they
call it a black comedy drama punch in
Rob
epic period black comedy drama
you watched this whole movie yes
but what I saw Bohemian Grove had major
shades of this and if I can't just
because I never do this on Big Shows
we're struggling to stay on air we still
have a huge audience that Tunes in and
our work gets seen everywhere but it's
kind of like I'm in a prison and then I
send letters out if people want to find
what we're actually doing and what's
going on band.video they block sharing
that link so mad maxworld.tv obviously
there's the famous infowars.com but I'm
on the air 11 A.M to 3 P.M every day of
another great talk show host uh I'm
going to be hosting my show tomorrow
night uh from Tampa at the riverchurch
at revival.com we're going to simulcast
that then I'm going to do a meet and
greet and ask Alex Jones anything at 7
pm at the River Church in Tampa uh
Sunday night
so I guess that's Pastor Rodney's church
that's Pastor Rodney Howard Brown out
there so so that's gonna be going on and
I mean we I still have my crew we're
still able to pay the bandwidth bills
the satellite uplinks we're on a lot of
TV stations and cable stations as well
and we're fighting and and the enemy's
trying to shut us down but you know you
ask how do I pay the bills you asked
that earlier yes uh we're in a chapter
11 sub chapter 5 which is a
reorganization and if the company's
viable even though the other side just
wants us silenced uh that under federal
law continues and the judge says we've
done a good job everything's proven up
the way we said it was it's a viable
company uh and uh so it looks like
that's gonna probably go through in the
next few months and then the bankruptcy
will go forward and my company won't be
shut down I personally didn't declare
bankruptcy until I had the billion 500
million dollar judgment that kicked me
up into pure chapter 11. so I can't do
that but it's a catch-22 because I don't
have a bunch of stuff uh and some of
them I'm wearing 20 t-shirts but this is
how I like to live and so uh plus I
don't have a you know sharp like you you
guys look like athletes But but so so
you know the message is they haven't
hurt me very bad they haven't silenced
me in fact they've made me bigger and I
kind of want to say folk hero-ish now
because of the because the system's so
demonized people say this guy's getting
massively demonized uh he must be good
so it's not that I'm that good it's that
anything that people now see as the
establishment hating they love and and
so that's what this happened and I want
my enemies to know you've not silenced
me but I'm not even your enemy I want
you to stop destroying yourselves you've
lost all credit I'm kind of like the FBI
back before they were really corrupt
saying come out with your hands up and
it'll go better for you the New World
Order is failing everybody sees who you
are it isn't working anymore I just want
my children to have a future and I
really want to have like an Armistice
with the globalist and then have an open
discussion about the way civilization's
going because we haven't even gotten
into Russia and I'm glad to talk about
myself but folks this is the most this
is way more dangerous the Cuban Missile
Crisis this is this
guaranteed the a a a globalist coup
counter coup power struggle
in Russia is going on right now no one
knows what the truth is I I have I can
talk about the angles of it I'm sure you
guys we talked before we went live are
are amazing but this this this is I mean
I am at a gut level instinctively uh
concerned for my family and concern for
us I mean I actually feel good being in
a four foot wall safe facility right now
Alex before we get to Russia because I
know we do want to cover that you said
something a second ago that I think
would be appropriate to bring up you
said when they tried to silence you when
they tried to cancel you it's actually
has a reverse effect you actually end up
getting bigger look at Chuck if he's had
five million viewers a night yeah now
his average show 60 million and then
this is reminiscent of an interview we
just did two weeks ago with the one and
only Andrew Tate as brother Tristan Tate
I know you've had some relationships
with them he's only getting bigger as
they try to silence him and cancel them
you've had some experiences with Tate
you're following that story what do you
think yeah I was one of the first people
to interview him in the U.S Paul Watson
was friends with him when he was on Big
Brother they hung out a lot and uh they
used to go out and you know double date
and stuff because these are both big
tall you know handsome guys uh and uh
total gentleman to woman totally nice
all of it's pure crap uh you know half
the women that supposedly said this said
that they never said that they wouldn't
charge them for a year and a half it's
it's pure
the fact that he was the most Google
person and everything he did was get 100
million views and they're just scared of
any any man that pops up that threatens
their Monopoly because what might stand
up against the globalist or take over
the planet men and so any man they can't
buy any man they can't intimidate any
man they can't destroy they come after
you with sex and let me just tell you I
think he did some racy stuff they did
the cam stuff they made a lot of money
he had a former police officers and
people running it uh that that's his
right to do it I I think he painted a
Target on his back but I don't think he
knew how big he was going to get and
that that would then happen that said
I'll break some news here
we had
from the other side trying to shut us
down recently this has even in the
Washington Post the justice department
trying to indict me and then even the
judge Department said this guy didn't do
anything on January 6th he tried to stop
it we can't charge innocent man that was
in The Washington Post it's crazy enough
they're still got Jack Smith trying to
do it claiming on masterminded but Trump
it's just ridiculous uh but they've had
uh the CIA because we know who the
people are they're dumb enough where we
can get their license plates and track
them and you know much of my guys have
worked and work at the CI is nothing I
mean that's like the low level you know
thing on my guy's resume you know
everybody's work for the CIA that works
for the military and all that stuff and
the state department and everything else
and then they have the CIA they had
British intelligence
um and they've had uh these the through
these cutouts uh with uh big
International Pi private investigation
units literally combing through and
getting Facebook images from like 10
years ago and right where a woman took a
picture with me and they call her up and
say you had a relationship with Alex
Jones did he or did he rape you well you
know the woman's like he I think I saw
him once at a movie theater and I took a
picture with him I've had dozens of more
than dozens of women call the office and
say hey I only met Alex once at a party
and the the the the the the you know
this group's coming to me
so then they try to go to the security
companies and that I've used and try to
get hire them oh the you know this rich
person from whatever wants to hire you
and then they get to the interview and
it's all about me and hey well you know
and it's like does he does he ever rape
women well you know so so that's what
they're doing to me except I'm not doing
that okay so I work hard you know eat
too much you know drink too much
sometimes and I go home and you know
throw my six-year-old around the pool
and hang out my other three children
that are basically grown uh you know 21
uh 18 and 15. so to me especially under
this attack more than ever it's all
about family that's my refuge that's
what it's all about and then they
literally have multinational groups and
intelligence agencies scouring going
we've got to get somebody to to and look
they're they're they'll probably find a
woman I don't even know like with his
Trump lady you know he was found guilty
by a jury not of raping a Woman They
said no we didn't find he raped her but
he defamed her by saying he's innocent
Trump said he was innocent five million
dollars and I'm sure after a certain
point it's like an escape room yeah if
you've seen a clip with her and uh
Anderson Cooper yeah but she says women
really love getting raped yeah no she
said I need everything physically
touching it it's such an emotional rape
oh yeah no you should you seen this clip
we'll play it again yeah this club never
gets old when she says you know I really
like you Anderson and he gets
uncomfortable he looks like he wants to
stop the I don't know he's not a truck
he's not even a woman he's attracted to
men yeah exactly I don't think I don't
think she fully understood that he's gay
yeah exactly exactly he's trying to come
on to a gator she's like listen one lady
who looks like the chick from uh four
year old virgin if I'm gonna make the
switch it ain't gonna be for you well
she also looks like the monster from
before it turns to the Stay Puft
Marshmallow Man oh my god oh that's
hilarious are you a God
no big guy
don't you love how Congressman Gozer has
the same name as the demon god Go sir
that's closer The Eliminator ghost of
the Traveler's Destroyer
dozers on CNN you play the clip play the
clip don't feel like a victim I was not
thrown on the ground and ravish which
the word rape carries so many sexual
connotations this was not this was not
sexual for it just it it hurt it just
what it just you know I think most
people think of rape as a I mean it is a
violent assault it is not I think most
people think of rape as being sexy what
is a fantasy look
you're fascinating to talk to
you I don't know I've seen many Clips on
over again than this and he's revolted
he literally goes like
oh you're fascinated you're not as tight
funny but listen I found I found tapes
of this lady I mean she one night I
literally spent like three hours finding
clips and I didn't send them to the crib
I never played him on air she literally
hopping around in the woods I mean she
is a fruit ball man I mean I mean in the
encyclopedia should say you know
fruitcake Wing bat and it's a picture in
fact that's Uncle before we go to the
road so so uh Alex Jones so you let's
say uh you have a crystal ball Alex
before you started this Crusade and who
you are right now to this day and you
could see everything that they've done
and where you're at right now do you
change anything do you do anything
different not to get to because you saw
what's what they did what they're doing
to you
you know hindsight's 2020 and I see how
God works How the Universe Works the
Lord Works mysterious ways yeah I would
have done a lot of things different I
didn't realize how influential I was
even 15 years ago and I would just be
doing five six hours a day some days and
just having fun sometimes I do nighttime
shows at a few martinis and you know say
stuff tongue-in-cheek and and then that
let them spin it and do things and then
take it out of context uh but that
probably added to the success at the end
of the day so it's all in God's hands
I've never tried to lie I've never tried
to hurt innocent people
but I have had a big footprint and I
have stepped on people and I'm sorry for
that uh but the past is the past and I
you know I don't even really look back
at the past uh uh I mean I studied the
past understand the future but
I'm just trying to improve myself now
and just trying to get as humble as
possible and just really praying that we
don't have a nuclear war and that we can
just have a future I really I mean used
to I wanted to be number one and I would
get a little jealous of other people
that were really successful uh but the
best thing in my life has been really
realizing it's the human Continuum and
that we're all basically on the same
journey together and other people's
success against tyranny is My Success so
I'm the happiest I've ever been uh and
uh and I just all the persecution has
been wonderful uh it's really taught me
a lot and uh and it's helped me be a
better person so I I want to thank my
enemies for everything they've done to
me and I want to encourage them not to
be destroyed by their master that will
destroy them and I want to have a future
with them on a planet we can all live on
and so I want to tell my enemies I love
you and I care about you and Jesus loves
you and you just need to ask Jesus to
come into your heart and God will set
you on the right path and forgive you
and then that's really the answer and I
would just really encourage them to find
God because let me tell you God and the
devil are real you better get that
straight yep where did this come from
man how long did it take this Epiphany
phase this is like what you're basically
saying is like you've been humbled right
you were at the top of the podium and
then boom you've been brought down
everything that's happened to you is it
is it Pastor Rodney is it you're reading
the Bible well you're you're praying for
your enemies you you've always been I
mean I've always been a Christian but
then I kind of slip out of here and turn
into the Tasmanian devil uh I mean
literally it's the Angel and the devil
like sometimes I like before I know okay
but I'm always I'm faith I'm faithful to
God I want to be here but I can jump
over to the devil really easy and and so
I've always been forgiven and I've
always loved other people's success one
of the best things I've always been
grateful and I've never it's just that I
catch myself saying well I like that
person but still they really do great
job and you know what it's like and but
that's all of our wealth together uh and
so really enjoying the wealth of other
people's success is all our human
success communist and socialists
authoritarians totalitarians they in
that movie The Book oil that was made in
the movie There Will Be Blood it's such
a powerful scene maybe you can pull it
up it's only like 30 seconds long where
he says
General Day Lewis probably the best
actors ever you know he says I have a
competition in me I don't like to see
other people do well and and I don't
like other people and he's like saying I
want to like you because you're my
cousin then later he learns he's faking
and he looks like his cousin he kills
him but you know imagine being alone
like he says I just won't have enough
money to be left alone and be you know
completely walled off and
uh he's just not happy and and so I want
to be the opposite but you can't just be
like oh everything's yours and I'm going
to roll over to you you got to be strong
for your family strong for culture fight
tyrants to build a free market system
where we don't make people be Christian
but they want to be Christian because
that's the way they know that's going to
be successful and Empower them and and
you know have them be with God forever
and so it really is a fight good versus
evil and now people that were agnostic
very famous people
are are having spiritual experiences
some of them are having incredible
experiences with like angels and you
know the Holy Spirit and God others are
literally don't believe anything are
laying in their beds and a huge black
shadow comes in and just rips off their
shirt into huge bloody slashes across
them and then just throws them up
against the wall and then they they
start finding out well okay what do they
do and uh you know they go to a rabbi he
says put this cabal on and do this
ritual doesn't help him they finally go
get born again all of it leaves and and
you know this is this is this is
happening with sane well-known people
that were you know not atheists they
didn't hate Christians they're like ah
come on you know I don't really believe
in God and they're and they're having
the experience uh because if you don't
have God around you as a defense Shield
you are wide open and and the devil
can't help it and whatever this feels
for us call the devil It's gotta because
if you're doing good work but but you
don't know it's God and and have God is
literally a shield it's like being in a
submarine with screen doors you're dead
and so this stuff's going to come in if
you don't have God so that's why I'm
talking about God because I need I need
to get closer to God I need God God is
my refuge God gets all the glory not me
Alex you're saying accepting God
accepting God Jesus is the Lord of
Savior you're saying you have to accept
Jesus uh all right well I'm Jewish uh
respect we're the OG Christian I'm not
putting no no no no that's not what I'm
asking no uh we have a lot of Muslim
friends a lot of Islam Andrew Tate just
turned to uh to to a Muslim
um abrahamic Faith as I'm asking and I
wasn't putting down you know the rabbi
this was a real story I was telling you
and then and that didn't work so I'm
just I'm not saying every I'm not I
wasn't a judgment like like this
gonna work great this one didn't I
wasn't like that but your overall
concept of faith and finding God and you
a lot of yours you just said sometimes
I'm the God and sometimes everything's
going on right there and everything that
you've uncovered with these Satanic
rituals and everything at the um the one
place up in California I mean Grove and
this you talked about they're praying to
the devil and they're sacrificing the
children and everything like this do you
feel like it's just a fight of believing
in God
versus the doubt 100 is that what it
comes down to yeah archetypes I mean for
people that are you know I'm not going
to try to just push nothing but
Christianity people but that's that's
what I believe that's what I know but
absolutely the first step is to realize
there is good and evil there's stuff we
don't see there's other dimensions and
none of these globalists are atheists
they're all under the occult they're all
into weirdness they're all super
neurotic and uh or they're super scared
of God I just don't want to hear about
it like Rupert Murdoch let's let's talk
about let's go let's actually by the way
if you want to play this clip that he
was talking about with Daniel Lewis and
let's go into the Bohemian growth and
it's in the first minute or so
volume okay then don't worry about it
good call okay
pause it pause it Rob okay there you go
and just kind of go away from it uh okay
thank you Andres for that so let's talk
about Bohemian Grove so you know if for
the audience that doesn't know obviously
Bohemian Grove has been done on by a lot
of different people but uh this is one
of the first things that you did almost
like a vlog stop before anybody was
doing Vlogs you know Alex Jones was
doing vlogs
this is a clip before we play this clip
can you tell everybody what this clip is
all about before Rob plays it sure and
again people can search around and find
HD versions of this at band.video so and
I'm gonna tell you to go there but if
you go to band on video you're welcome
to use it all and just type in Alice
Jones David gergen or Alex Jones
Bohemian Grove you can find it's not an
HD but it's in a lot better quality but
all this stuff it's fine at this point
don't go yeah go go down I'm just
telling folks so it's a plug but so but
you're right so
again I'm a Christian I believe in God
but God's kind of like something that
happens on Sunday and it's like a jacket
I wear once a week it's kind of like
over here I believe in God I love Jesus
uh but you know devils and all this
stuff whatever so
I've been on there a few years four or
five years and
John Ronson when I'm out there doing a
story about the Waco Massacre and we're
digging up the the
soil and stuff to show that they did
fire in
um incendiary grenades to set the place
on fire we actually found some of those
so we're out there digging and this in
this British film BBC crew comes along
and he says he says his name's John
Ronson he says Alex I I hear Alex I hear
that you snuck into some military bases
and been able to and which I've done and
shown some martial law train that was
going on he said we have liability and
they won't let me get into Bohemian
Grove but I have a lawyer that works
there uh who actually uh has some of the
passcodes and things and and how to not
get kicked out of the Secret Service or
the uh Monterey Sheriff's Department
that's all over the place like 50 of
them in their lease that I saw uh but
also Secret Service and others because
presidents of them go there and royalty
and Prince Charles and all of it and he
said there's this Big Al God and they
worship on the 15th of July every year I
think they've now pushed it later in
July but for 15 days in July all these
world leaders go there it's 2 700 acre
Redwood Grove and he goes I just need
you to go in there with a hidden camera
I need you to get us the footage and
then I need you to air it on your Access
TV show because my lawyers tell me and
they're just being honest about all this
my lawyers tell me that then we'll be
able once it's fair use and out in the
open you can give us the authorization
to use it but you've got to hear it
first and he said how much money do you
want
and I said well I don't okay there's
guys in the woods worshiping out I said
is this the KKK or something he goes no
no it's very liberal it's founded by
Mark Twain but then the President Taft
took it over in 1900 which was all true
and I go wait I've heard from some of
the shortwave or militia people there's
a thing called Bohemian Grove they
worship it out that's why I did research
and called him back and I said y'all do
it he says okay well we're going to go
this next July it's like a year later
and so it comes time I fly out there
have a little you know DB cams just come
out this little pecan-pac camera put the
fanny pack
and uh basically it was all true it
happened it was insane so you talk about
making your faith stronger imagine the
five hours I'm in there so it's it's on
the Russian River totally beautiful it's
the biggest stand of redwood trees
outside of the big National Park in
California 2 700 Acres of of trees you
can drive a truck through okay and
so and it's in the middle of a Gorge and
then goes out over the Russian River so
you can only get in in one entrance and
it's a Gorge and the gorge entrance is
about a hundred yards wide okay and then
there's Hills that go up to it and and
the most elite things called The Chalet
where presidents and royalty go and have
secret meetings and I was never up at
the Chalet
um I was uh I was uh down on the bottom
and I went back to the back to the
swimming platform and then back to the
front and it was several miles in and I
got questioned several times by secret
service but just imagine
I get there and then it's copyright free
trademark where you can use all my
Bohemian Grove footage however you want
you can show it to people what's the
best place to go to show some BTS some
behind the scenes uh I would say uh
band.video and I would just type in
Bohemian Grove or it's on YouTube you
can type in Alex Jones Bohemian Grove uh
or dark secrets inside Bohemian grub or
the order of deaths the second film I
made about it and it's you know it's
it's color just look for it on YouTube
to see if it's easy to find it yeah
you're welcome to show all the b-roll of
it and so
long story short it's a long time for
five hours about Bohemian Grove
it's it's July 15th 2020. and uh
and so they've told me some of the
passcodes they've got maps from the
internal members that they give the
members
um they gave me passcodes different
camps because it's like a little little
camps of cabins and stuff and like bars
and things there they're built all over
100 camps and so
they had told me that I should try to
walk through and use the passcode to get
in to the guard shack uh but do you
remember what the passcode was
it was stuff like I'm with the
hillbillies uh Red Mountain
that was I'm with you Alex Jones I'm
here with the hillbillies all right well
I chose that but that's the Bush's camp
and the Texas Camp it's like a Texas
Camp that's that's kind of Midway up
and that worked and I had a few other
passcodes it was like Hillbillies uh
were you shocked what's the rest of the
passcode well that's that's what camp
here the passcode was Red Mountain yeah
were you shocked when it worked you're
like holy [__] that just worked well
I'll tell the story so yeah so oh my God
so they pull up to the entrance and
there's like a bog and a little bit of a
swamp Rider off the road and they go
okay Alex you're gonna walk through and
I had a feeling and I saw that they were
pulling cars in the park in a parking
lot over here and picking him up on
these big flat back buses that had the
tops cut off like 1940s buses
open air buses and and so uh it's like a
double decker but one deck and it's just
opened and I and so and I made a split
second decision
uh to uh step off and go through the
barbed wire fence uh this is before the
checkpoint and just act like I was in
the parking lot and get on one of those
and so we just sailed through oh wow
because Mike Hanson uh my uh producer
also went in with me because it would be
better to be up two people people aren't
usually alone and Mike uh is big and fat
like me now too he's a great guy but but
he was really good looking guy and I was
really good looking so I didn't
understand what Nixon had said about it
I hadn't done that much research once we
get in immediately people start
whistling at me oh man and uh and so
whistling like in a sexual yes and the
workers are wrestling this is a I mean
should call it the most GD [__] thing
you've ever seen that's a quote that's a
White House yeah listen to this place
this is his audio
[Music]
just Terror it's just terrible
and he was quite the man's man uh and
could have been a for now people that
know Nixon was supplying with the women
he was quite quite quite the opposite of
homosexual uh and every reason he had
the nickname a tricky dick too
well that's a little inside
but anyways anyway so people are
whistling at you and trying to like so
you're yeah yeah so so set the time
you're young you're hot you're a young
Alex Jones you're on the scene this is
year 2000 they're whistling boom yeah so
I'm immediately so we get off and I'm
like okay I got a map here uh I'm gonna
go see the owl to make sure this is real
because the pawn supposedly only like a
half mile down so I'm going in the gorge
and people are walking by and I'm like
that's a senator that's a [__] I know
who's that like you recognize people
because you've seen them but you're
trying to think who is that they're
basically all famous and uh you're
you're walking Hollywood guys that's a
major musician that they bring them all
in it's guests so a thousand members but
most guests can bring one guest the
actual members bring one guest you get a
plus one it's like 2 000 people
and so I saw Clint Eastwood when I was
in there I saw Danny Glover so so but
you want to say hey clinics what other
names what other famous people did you
see well a lot of them I don't even I
don't even go back in memory but it was
it was quite a few and like there's that
Senator and there's like oh gosh that
Senator knows me kind of oh my God so
all of a sudden I'm walking by this big
pond like there's the big 45 foot out oh
my gosh there's the and they already had
it like hitting it ready or by the side
like this battle like a mummy but like a
child the mock sacrifice they burn so I
saw that I'm like okay because later
people snuck back in but never got video
but they got photos of the two second
over the years I've learned more so
I go back down to the platform takes me
like a mile and a half back
it was a big platform above the Russian
River it's beautiful and all of a sudden
hey what are you guys doing and it's the
sheriff and he's got another Sheriff's
deputy with him and we're like what's
going on like oh just checking out it's
beautiful they're kind of looking at us
like yeah yeah and we know what you guys
are because we're like properly dressed
you know and I guess their gaydar was on
but I'm not gay but they thought it was
you did a fanny pack too so that kind of
knows what did a sheriff mean we know
what you guys are what does that what
did that mean we know where you guys no
no no no he's like what are you guys
doing and I'm like oh we're with the
hillbillies how are you doing and in
that type of tournament yeah
he's like he's like what's the passcode
I go uh Red Mountain he goes all right
all right well have fun so they go back
so
and then we go back and I see like this
big bar and music and all these guys
walking around with wine and stuff it's
like let's go in there I want to drink
because I'm like you know this is really
wet my appetite I'm nervous I'm not
going like a red wine red wine like a
red wine red wine and then guys are
coming over they're talking to me and
they're looking at me and like people
are like hey what's going on I'm like
whoa this is like a gay bar so I go okay
I'm getting out of here me and Mike
Mike's like what's going on here and
like he goes one of those guys just
pinched me on the butt didn't I swear
this happened and so we go out all of a
sudden it's Secret Service and like like
blue vest
um yes uh what's your name and I'm like
oh Alan Alan Johnson what's up and they
didn't actually like well uh who are you
with I'm with the hillbillation
and they go okay they didn't ask the
code word any of that and uh
so that goes on and and and and then uh
we get questioned again and this time
uh two golf carts pull up with more
sheriff's deputies and these are younger
ones not who you guys with were you just
down yeah I'm here with the hillbillies
what's going on I'm a guest they said
all right all right
and I realized I was going uphill
towards the Chalet and I said maybe
you're not supposed to go up here this
is like like the bushes are down here
this is like this is like royalty and
people up here and just to make sure are
you filming this the whole time no
because they only had one hour tapes in
this little camera so I kind of had an
hour getting in I got a little bit at
the floating platform and stuff it's in
a two-hour film and then I got and then
I got some right it was getting dark
which is incredible and then I got the
ritual and it ran out magically right at
the end so
but this is the rest of the story
because I can talk about 10 hours but
it's amazing so I tell Mike I said we've
got to hide and there's this like uh
another like a crappy uh cabin I go I
bet that's a worker cabin and so I go in
there and mine's like this is nice let's
just stay in here and I say no we got to
get under the building they're going to
find us in there there's cameras so we
go out under the back in case they've
got cameras and uh open up like a
access uh panel and we get under this
thing and there's like millipedes and
spiders because I don't want to be in
here I said we're staying here buddy
we're about to get our cover blown okay
yeah there's footage I got and well
there's photos are similar to the photo
so so I'm up above that because the
chalets up here like we're talking steep
in these golf carts that are going by
we're hiding up at a thing up above that
starts getting dark and I go okay let me
reload the camera get ready I've got a
little hole in it here with a hole in
the front I can lift up this is a
makeshift where I can hit the butt on
the back
and uh I say uh let's go down Twilight
and we're walking down there's bats
flying in the air and stuff it's real
beautiful and we and we're coming down
this this road and there they're playing
dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun
dun dun dun and and there's a orchestra
playing
and they're all eating and there's these
giant tables and I can just smell the
food that's looking good I'm like 100
yards cat
but now it's getting dark so I feel safe
and everybody's drunk by then
there goes Danny Glover walking by
and there's a couple of these really old
man they go and I'm not trying to be
racial and feed into the whole leftist
thing but this is the old white guys I
can't believe they let that Genie
they're in here it's all right so this
is kind of stuff you're picking up then
it covers the only black guy in there I
think they have more now but this is two
thousand this is like it's like a 90
year old billionaires watch that black
person
goodness uh this actually happened so
but it was like more axle attack to
whatever and like it's all right it's
all right and I think in a distance I
saw Vernon Jordan or something too but
the point is is that
is that it's like Bilderberg he's always
the deal the black guy that's there a
big lobbyists and so that happens and uh
and that's when I saw Clint Eastwood
because now everybody's going down to
the water so you go around the owl
almost Bank uh to then see the owl about
60 70 yards away and so now it's getting
dark
and this high priest comes out and his
white rubs and red cape and he's got the
staff and he he he says let the dad who
were here were before us their Spirits
be here and so they did and they go
through like this cornucopia
of of of like Babylon gods and and they
summon all these different gods and they
said but we summon the most powerful
that God is to renew us the next year
and give us strength and rebuild our
bodies and give us the thing we need and
we bring an offering forward to to our
god so that we will be able to you know
put all of our all of our sin and
trouble onto it and then this open uh
ornate
I'd say like 18th century British
carriage
comes out with big glass sides with a
coffin on it a like a five-year-old
sized coffin like a five-year-old child
would be in and they uh a bunch of high
a bunch of priests like with a whole
bunch of guys with torches I got all
this on video come out guys with torches
in front of uh the people uh I think it
was like
four people bearing the coffin
and they take the energy of the child
out and put it in front of it and then
they then they and I learned it was the
voice of Walter Cronkite he did it like
right before he died and so it's like
and it's when we forward to see you now
[Applause]
and then
he said yes
and and and I'm sitting there going like
it's a play they're not taking this
serious and I'm having to kind of stand
up on the bottom of the Redwood knobs
because a lot of these guys are bigger
than me I'm only like 510 trying to get
the camera get over so I'm kind of like
up on the tree and there's these guys
are looking at me all these old men and
I'm sitting there and I'm like I just
saw him and these old men are sitting
there just going
because like like I'm a Christian but
you go to like a Holy Roller church and
they that it's great and it's wonderful
but they're like in Rapture and you're
like wow these people were but like in a
satanic type deal they were just going
ah
and I'm like and I'm like hey this is
pretty cool
oh my God I'm just like and and Mike was
kind of hey how's it going they're like
this is important
and so you're like well they're a dead
serious and this is the Karl robe of
five administrations now of like four at
the time and David gergen is four years
later at the RNC in New York yeah and
I'm I've got full credentials and stuff
and I'm waiting to go in and do more
interviews on radio row real quick
before we get to this the guys are they
praying are they in the Rapture the
these they're devilish faces people
doing a Christian Church yeah where
they're on the roller coaster yeah well
I mean they feel the spirit of God it's
good to do that uh and you know reach
out to God so so this is this they're
they're standing there going like oh
they're possessed oh they're soaking it
up by the way where is this when you
confront him in New York uh Alex what
location this is this is Madison Square
Garden okay let's see let's see VIP
entrance go ahead and play it Rob and
that's the Bohemian Grove and back in
what was the 19 uh
96 when you joined uh as a Clinton
advisor they were the Republicans were
criticizing you oh what about Bohemian
Grove and then you counter uh and then
you countered them by saying hey I don't
run around in the woods naked what did
that mean here is the before mentioned
Washington Times article where he said I
didn't run around naked like they do
I don't I don't know what I don't know
what quote you're referring to I'm not
aware of any quote like that uh listen
uh I am
a a happy member of the Bohemian Grove I
like the the folks who come there and uh
it's really inappropriate for me to talk
about a uh uh the group beyond that cool
thank you have you been there for the
ceremony with the The Cremation of care
uh frankly that I don't think that's
something I need to talk to you about
this is it
[Music]
later got documents have you been there
for the ceremony with the The Cremation
of care uh frankly that's uh that I
don't think that's something I need to
talk to you about
that's right
Jones and I snuck in there in 2000. blew
it wide open
[Music]
wide open well I disrespect you for that
you do you do I do
public officials going in there we
deserved enough you took it I don't know
anything about you and I don't know
about your film but if you go in there
with an understanding you violated that
understanding by releasing that film and
I don't respect you for that wow really
I'm sorry you took an understanding when
you went in there that you would not do
that film and you did you have an
understanding when you went in there the
secret society Alex
yeah and it has no trespassing signs
there too doesn't it oh I'm sorry I'm
sorry sir I've been there before I know
and I'm sorry you violated the
understanding that was not a gentleman
anything to do what about the ritual is
the ritual genuinely
like what is the dude it's like a movie
it's like Eyes Wide Shut
sure everything you I I I don't owe you
this comment you you have you this is
what's called Ambush journalism and I
disrespect you for that as well so thank
you
and violate them
you you ambush people on the streets
when that's that's inappropriate form of
Journalism if you wish to practice that
that's fine but don't ask others to
respect you for it you want to you you
can do your free American like anything
you want if you want to be uncivil and
rude and ungenly that's up to you but
don't expect the rest of us to say oh
wow Mr gergen I'm sorry nobody says
policy in there we try to be gentlemen
and obviously you don't belong there
weaving spiders come out here
yeah that is a three-pointer
but that guy is no lightweight he's been
a presidential advisor for for Carter
he's basically Reagan Clinton he's still
on CNN I don't know if it was Carter I
think it was Ford but he's he's been
around the block he's been around the
block doing so after that you know what
else did you learn about Bohemian Grove
well there's a whole other story so
uh we we get in the hotel they want
copies of us they have their digital
camera article camera we transfer it
they check it it's there we I watch them
check it on their little TV so they have
a film crew outside waiting on me
they mail it to World of wonder in La it
comes erased
then they get me to send them another
copy that I saw had it that one gets
stolen and then we had to mail it from
somebody else's house to one of their
crew members houses so they were
intercepting our footage this is like
CIA stuff trying to get it to to to the
producers and stuff so they would have a
copy obviously I had my original and I
went off and put out my film
uh but um they uh I got I got some
really serious death threats over it I
had some stuff happen and uh but you
want to play the John Ronson clip on
what he said because he wanted to take
credit for the whole thing I believe
right yes or no I think yeah yeah so
yeah he well what what what what's sad
is he does get credit for it but he's
such a liar uh he's since then written
pieces about me they're totally untrue
he went and created a uh history piece
for NPR uh on one of their big Sunday
show is American Rose whatever is I
forget the name and it's literally
completely made up it's like an origin
story that I would beat up nerds and
they nerds got me and tied me up in a
barn and knocked all my teeth out and I
went and when he was fact checking and I
said my dad's a dentist but I'll go to a
doctor they can x-ray that none of my
teeth have ever been knocked out and he
goes well they still so you make this
whole fake origin story about me because
you wrote an article saying I feel like
I have to destroy Alex Jones because I
feel like I made him because Bohemian
Grove did explode no I made myself go in
there and getting it buddy and you did
you were part of it but don't he said I
am enraged that I made Alex Jones
Bohemian Grove really put me on the map
and I was already successful and big but
it exploded back then and and so yeah I
I one morning I get a call from Mike
Hanson and he goes because he goes
he goes John Ronson's on C-Span line
about us and all this other stuff and
here he didn't go all the way on the
Brian Lamb thing he basically took some
credit but said I was like a bad guy
then he went on Coast to Coast AM as I
was friends with the the host and I knew
it was going on so I was tuned in well I
just called in the studio while he was
talking to him and said this is a lie of
the contract right here he made me sign
a contract that they would have rights
to it but I wouldn't tell anybody about
it because they needed me to air it so
they could air it so I did this thing
with him this conspiracy it's not
illegal yeah to cover his ass and then
he gets up there and says I'm bad when
he basically quarterbacked it and then
claimed he snuck in and got the footage
and stuff well yeah later he went the
lawyer and the passcodes came in but he
didn't get the footage which by the way
he'd sworn me to secrecy in a contract
to never say he went in then he spins it
around and says that I was taking the
credit from him
years after his documentary comes out
saying I snuck in and giving me all the
credit I mean the guy is it's like the
left doesn't know we can check what they
said before it's so annoying and I don't
even hate this guy he is the biggest
weasel I mean I I was glad he got me in
there I was thankful but then he he
literally creates an NPR hour-long
documentary about me that's literally
not true
other than one guy that attacked me and
and I did body slam him or knock him
over and he was in a coma for a while
that's the only thing but why wasn't I
arrested because all the witnesses said
he attacked me and outweighed me by 60
pounds so so yes that part of the story
is true that's it but I didn't get
arrested
but I mean it's just it's all crap so so
the whole story behind the Bohemian
Grove is these guys come together to do
what do they do deals are they making
decisions are they it's no longer as
private as it once once was they're not
alone I will tell you what it is and
then this is this is where it really is
interesting
much about it when I see
okay you're gonna pay gonna pay sneak in
and get guys worship and now on sure
okay I'll sneak into your Camp I mean I
wanted a free trip to Northern
California okay so again I'm a Christian
but I'm like okay devils and devil
worship that's people doing like on acid
and trailer parks okay the world the
leader not worshiping an hour yeah okay
this is what like you know crazy people
on meth do this is what actual
Hillbillies do yeah
I've heard about devil worshipers is
like you know weirdos in the middle of
nowhere yeah and and so long story short
um
what was the part I was going to get to
oh so after I do this
I um I start with my P.O box about a
year after we go to the P.O box there's
this big green book and it's the it's
the uh it's the annals so I think they
only come out like every yeah like every
four years it's a four year animal I've
got somewhere around the office
it disappeared somebody stole that thing
but the point is
it's it and later these things would
sell for like ten thousand dollars on on
on uh what's that thing eBay I mean I
didn't sell them but people started
selling them because the guys die
and their wives and family get them and
they don't tell their kids hey that's a
super valuable book that there's only
100 of them made every year so there's
these big bound books Green books some
of them read some of the points first
one I got is green I open it up it's
color photos of the rituals them dressed
up like women all this you know gay
stuff pictures of all the world leaders
it's like that thick I put it on the
internet so and the problem is Infowars
had problems and crashed the old model
we had trouble putting back up but but
yeah there it is
there's an example type in vintage
photos Bohemian Grove
and then once I exposed it uh National
Geographic put out them in satanic black
robes doing a human sacrifice uh with a
man and a dagger so once I exposed it
the floodgates opened and so they went
ahead and put it in National Geographic
they would have mock sacrifices of black
people there's one right there in the
lower right hand corner lower left hand
corner that's a lower left hand um it
was uh this one here Alex yeah that's
yeah they would do lynchings of black
people what man you can't make this up
okay oh my God uh and they would
actually really kill people is is the
word a lot of kids disappear in the area
but that's an inner cult so let me tell
you what it is we're hanging somebody in
the middle on the middle one skip
through this drop yeah we got it Go and
keep saying this I'm not making any of
this up this is so insane so all of a
sudden I show this handle on air and I
scan it onto my website Infowars now
it's getting millions of views and all
of a sudden about a month later they go
hey boss another one came
another one and I got this stuff back to
the 20s oh my God so I got I got and
they're smaller books in the 20s and
black and white photos there's this
stuff and it's like mock killing black
children and mock killing little girls
and and like there's a Reagan and
Eisenhower and uh Nixon right there
and that was in the animal I put that
out so this is not just a lesson my
scanner at my house I mean I got okay I
got that wow so so this is the stuff
that's one from like the the 70s
uh and so
that's where all this goes down and and
so then I became an expert on it and
then the media would do stuff like well
it doesn't exist but here it is and it's
harmless you know that weird thing they
do uh like sure it gives you blood clots
but they're harmless so cancer yeah it's
connected to the cancer big deal and
everybody gets it so remember all those
articles now cancer is up but it's no
big deal
um but that's what I'm telling you
people that's why I'm so animated when
I'm hanging out with the pastor and
stuff they go man you're like low energy
when we're driving here and you know you
want to take a nap when I start
accessing all the stuff I've done in 29
years it's it's all just completely
insane and it all happened I mean I've
got stories even crazier than this and
uh
now the stuff I've learned and it's just
it's it's we're not in Kansas anymore we
were never in Kansas and
these people so here's what it is I
learned this from their animals they
mentioned men in Powers a political
retrospective written by Helmut Schmidt
the German Chancellor
and so I went to the library found the
book uh the library had to send off for
it and he says in the book and it's in
my film shots of it he said we love our
rituals our druidic sacrifices in
Germany and and and in other areas
because we are you know we're Druids but
my favorite place to do our druidic uh
rides is is that the chapter of you know
the order of death uh at uh Bohemian
Grove
and so what it is is a Germanic death
cult uh that's part of it that then
founded skull and bones and then Skull
and Bones members learned about this
Mark Twain had set it up where they just
partied and got drunk and brought in
prostitutes
um that got shut down it became an
all-male club and by around it was
always all male but they made the hooker
stay like a camp right by it which is
now hotels what the hookers say today
like gentlemen do yeah what the men are
in here but the male prostitutes get
brought in exactly and uh
so so basically it's a recruiting ground
and so they don't have skull and bones
at Yale they have these skull and bones
at all the elite Ivy League colleges
where they go hey son we're we're
bisexual devil worshipers and you're and
you're the firstborn son and you're
doing good at Yale you go getting these
these these coffins you have demons
enter you you have gay sex you get
urinated on you you bathe for three days
and baptizing feces and this is all this
is what this is this is all in the Good
Shepherd produced by Robert De Niro
starring Matt Damon which is a true
story about the founding of the CIA out
of skull and bones and it shows them
bathing in feces and urinating on each
other this is real
and and Charlotte Israel's dad was in it
she released the documents to the uh
Church committee hearings in the 70s the
first time they started to come out so
so most of the members have been
inducted into these cults
uh and then they they they and then this
is just like for graduates of it they go
to this and then they can they get to
recruit somebody they like to see if
they want to be part of it
and it's not all homosexual you know a
lot of the guys are heterosexual and
there's a lot of famous bands in there I
mean you name it that you know that come
and play uh and there's a lot of famous
actors and it's not just like dudes
everywhere running around having sex
with each other but I mean that's that's
that's the big overhang of it and that's
it and I mean
this is how they can so that's just the
interest is this is this a is this a way
to compromise well I don't know about
compromise is this a way of now that we
have this on you we can control you
forever and we can have it from the
beginning is that one method because yes
and then they move on to the Jeffrey
Epstein method you nailed it this is
about compromising people okay so so if
I invite you to Epstein now that you've
been here guess what for the rest of
your life we're gonna say you've been at
this party if we want to leak it to them
to the to the media and in one way or
another you're controlled and
compromised because the world can think
about well maybe if you went there as
well you did something as well so and
this is key what you just said I should
have got this the first this is their
whole whether it's Nexium or whether
it's Jeffrey empty or whether it's this
it's all these different feeders
basically the same group to see what
they want do they want women do they
want money do they want men do they want
power and yes they then
the elite ivy league people put their
kids in it and then they teach them how
to go out and recruit other people what
a shitty way of being arrested for the
rest of your life knowing you're
controlled if that's the case well
imagine your dad when you're going to
Yale says son you're the captain of the
football team now it's time for you to
go lay in a coffin and have men have sex
with you and defecate all over you and
you're like Dad I don't want to do that
I have a hard time believing that I have
a hard time believing believe it Robert
De Niro
made a movie about it and it's in the
annals people broke in there it was
they've got all these a hard time a
father telling his boy you're going to
go be a captain and they're going to
have sex with men but for the rest of
your I I well I mean it's their buddies
get them into it and but then but the
parents the ones that send them to this
yeah I mean look you know maybe a pair a
father has done that who's psycholog
psychologically off but I I don't see
that as well listen they admit the the
ritual there is days laying in a coffin
wanting entities to enter you and to get
a new personality and they get urinated
on and they swim in Vats of species well
urinated on there's there's a no type in
type in uh uh satanic uh uh Skull and
Bones ritual scene the Good Shepherd I
mean this is Robert De Niro produced a
movie that's a movie though
listen Charlotte is Ruby's dad was in it
she got the annals of it and leaked it
to the Senate this this stuff came out
in the U.S Senate all right so that's
that's one story we can leave it at that
I know it sounds over the top believe me
no you listen there's something I didn't
believe when they said they worship an
owl
yeah no to me to me there is worshiping
an owl is strange for sure but people
have worshiped a lot of weirder things
you know if it's a 48 foot owl or
whatever it is the worshiping of weird
things has been around since Biblical
times it's nothing new that uh people do
you know there should be no other God I
mean there's this isn't anything new
that happens but for father to say that
to his son that's a little weird the
part about trying to control you for the
rest of your life because they know if
you're going to Yale or Harvard you're
going to be one of these fraternities
and skull and bones they know you're
probably going to be somebody right John
Kerry is Yale you know exactly yes he's
skeleton so they know this dude's
probably going to be somebody he's from
the right family let's get them from now
so we can control them forever I can
believe a party that's it that's why we
have the Harvard yeah Mafia yeah I mean
look at that's that's the what I'm
telling you is and what I said it's
technically wrong I'm just talking fast
it's like the parents send their kids
there to be recruited into this I don't
think says you're gonna go do this the
the dad is pushing them into this to see
if they'll go along with it because
because you've got to debase yourself
you've got to prove you're going to do
this stuff you've heard fraternities
when you have sex with a goat well it's
all about debasing yourself yeah so and
that's what happens at skull and bones
I mean again Robert De Niro I mean
Robert Nero respected guy he produced a
movie about the history of the CIA being
founded at skull and bones and used the
Senate annals
and what came out in Anthony Sutton to
make the movie guys what happened is the
Good Shepherd uh ritual scene in into
like YouTube we can't play but but I
understand what you're saying from the
movie side so let's uh let's take a
two-minute break yeah of course
and by the way folks you can find all
this at infowars.com and I need your
support we have signed an unsigned
copies of the great reset in the war for
the world at infoworkstore.com and I
thank you for letting me do that Alex if
you want to you want to use a restroom
okay use the restroom come back we're
going to transition into the uh Russia
story which by the way I don't know if
you guys are following the story or not
they're Advanced on the cover of CNN on
the cover of Wall Street Journal on the
cover of every website you go on the
main story right now Rob if you want to
pull this up we'll teed us off before he
comes in the main story everybody's
talking about right now is what just
happened with Russia okay Russia and
Wagner group Russia's putting orders
military to crush Wagner group grab
calls it treason now here's a few things
you need to know about what this is
number one
the guide behind Wagner group is a guy
named I want to pronounce this correctly
evgeny progojin okay that's his name
evgen pregozian he's a billionaire it's
like a black water of Russia and this
guy's called his man to oust the
country's military leadership meaning
he's going directly against Putin's
military so we've got to oust the
military leadership and he claims the
war on Ukraine was based on false
pretense is they have roughly 25 000
soldiers okay these are a lot of uh
former ex Navy Seals you know these are
guys that are you know mercenaries oh
yeah these these are not regular types
of these are people that believe in the
cause of what's happening and not doing
their job because they have to do their
job they're doing their job because they
believe in what evgeny is talking about
sometimes people like this are True
Believers you know 10 soldiers that are
true believers going against 100 that
are just doing their jobs sometimes the
10 has an edge over the other hundred
because they believe exactly what
they're doing so Robin Hood exactly so
Putin responded the actions of Wagner
group are seen as treason there's a
warrant out for him right now uh they
got bombed I think he claims they got
bombed uh their unit got bombed they're
bombing some you know gas plane you know
different kind of places that they're
taking out Putin is telling them to get
this guy here this guy being a
billionaire you know there's a lot of
stuff that's going on right now in
Russia do you have one that Clips Rob to
show on what's going on there I think
there's a uh uh whether it's Putin given
a speech or him giving a speech or the
explosion you know I think one of the
videos uh uh uh Vinnie you may have
given to him yeah see because Pat
they're advancing right now towards
they're saying like they're going
towards Moscow right now yeah he's
advancing through the streets and
there's a bunch of vehicles blown up and
they're on to the side and he's actually
advancing there right now what's this
your Rob
lower the music just so we don't have to
is there any other thing to so this is
what this is them pulling up to who
well they took over a city called rostov
right and now they're basically marching
towards Moscow 25 000 soldiers a lot of
them actually recruited from prisons and
penal camps and they're they're
basically saying that this is the most
serious threat internally in Russia uh
essentially took over a Civil War in a
country that has twice the nuclear
weapons we have and it's happening right
now
so Alex what are your thoughts on what's
going on right now in Russia obviously
it's a breaking story it's all over the
place on cover of every website this is
all they're talking about what do you
know about the story absolutely I'm glad
we just spent and a half on me but I was
like let's not talk about me because
this I mean
what I really do study is geopolitics of
course you're a special ops guy and I
know your history you're super smart I
watch your show all the time you know
what you're talking about so I'm really
look forward to me shutting up here what
you have to say because I'll be honest
with people I didn't talk about the
submarine until Friday because I wanted
to see all the pieces and they lied to
us about that they knew it blew up on
Sunday they use it as distraction bare
minimum and I'm sorry for the dead
um and but on this subject
um last night we're driving in here and
I'm seeing this news and I'm thinking
this is so dangerous this can't be real
and we were out to dinner late and I saw
it last night that it looked like it was
real but I just couldn't fathom it so I
spent a lot of time this morning
researching this is obviously very fast
moving but let me just tell listeners
and viewers I think you'll probably
agree with me in any other Mainline
military analyst would this is the most
dangerous development in modern history
with nuclear weapons okay uh ladies and
gentlemen Russia has tactical news and
intermediate range and long-range
weapons all over Western Russia their
submarines are off our Coast uh if you
know Russian history if a leader fails a
war they always kill them
um Putin is a soft liner compared to the
hardliners uh that are trying to take
control
and uh the I don't know who's working
with NATO I don't know if it is how do
you pronounce his name out of trouble um
evgeny yes which is how do you say his
last name I was always butchered it
um the point is is that I'm having one
of those moments but it goes in this guy
progovic yes yes pergovic from Santa
right pergovic I have trouble with
Russian and
pregosian
see even though it's not a Russian agent
I don't know anything about it but
anyways pergocian I'm trying to draw the
data right now pagosian
uh is is obviously one of these
billionaire oligarchs that runs these
catering companies and he does a lot of
psyops with Putin is reportedly Putin's
best buddy and he's a former prisoner
and all the rest of it and he's a former
friend of Putin well well who's not
saying he wants to arrest him yes well
you guys have all the latest
developments what I'm saying is this
we know that NATO has back Channels with
the Russian Central Command and they're
both working to not have a nuclear war
behind the scenes so the question is is
it the Russian here's the different
scenarios I don't hear your take on it
is the Russian military
working with the West
is pregogin working with the last that
heads up the Wagner group
or are neither of those sides really
working with NATO and this is really an
internal uh Power struggle and then the
other question is well will NATO back
one of the two uh and then separately uh
is this really the Russian military that
just bombed pierogian in his troops
they're going to act like pergoian
launches this attack and then they're
really going to kill Putin and then say
it was pregogin this is this is this is
serious Cloak and Dagger fog of War I
don't think Putin really knows what's
going on uh because that's how Russia
operates it's total once the everybody
works in unison until the knives come
out and right now they're about all
these different factions all this
stuff's going on and the last time they
moved the chairs around in 1999 uh and
Boris Yeltsin disappeared you know we
got we got Putin uh so I don't think we
know what we do know is Russia is now
under martial law
and uh Moscow is under martial law and
what 25 30 000 battle-hardened
ex-convict survivors of the sixty
thousands half of them died that were
sent to uh Ukraine who are credited with
winning most of battles uh because
burgogen says that the Central Command
is working with the west and losing on
purpose uh and that they're trying to
you know undermine tanks and take out
Putin and he says Putin needs to believe
him uh now they say he's trying to come
kill Putin so Putin we haven't seen him
say this but we see him in text say it
that that he's going to get pregogin uh
and so I don't think we know at this
point this this is unbelievably riveting
uh this just gives me unlimited
adrenaline I mean I'll guarantee you I'm
going to be scanning and reading and and
on and up I'm gonna go to an emergency
broadcast today from from from uh the
pastor's place I've been here working
the whole time but I just absolutely
have to do this I'm glad we're here
covering it and now I'd like to hear all
the latest developments from you guys
and then see what you think Alex is this
one of those things where you're know
they say that the enemy of my my enemy
is my friend because this guy burgosian
the United States is issued an arrest
warrant for him in 2018. this has to do
with something something to do after the
2016 election I mean we can go there but
he's no friend of the states they've
been arrest warrant for him so I know
that you kind of alluded like what's the
NATO's involvement here what's going on
here is this an internal struggle you're
absolutely right there's definitely
you've got it up the internet there's
more questions than answers right now
but the average ongoing average American
is going to be like oh he's gonna put in
go get him people Americans that don't
know anything are going to be cheering
for this guy to to get Putin out they
have no idea what the hell they're
talking about you just you just brought
it to the key yeah and that's why the
brainstorm first there's so many pieces
and then I come up with my answer the
bottom line is Putin is a middle of the
road guy compared to the hardliners
pregogin wants martial law and nuclear
war with the West he's completely
psychotic I've watched his videos where
he says it and he's Fearless too he's
out on the front lines for like a year
and a half the guy's a maniac and so I
mean Patrick what do you think I mean
the bottom line is the bottom line is Oh
yeah exactly let's cheer get rid of
Putin yeah then there'll be a whole new
power struggle and you'll get a much
more radical Russia what do you guys and
that's why Soros in the west were crazy
nine years ago to overthrow the
Ukrainian government and then run these
Ops against the Russians to get them to
come in just make no mistake I'm not for
the Russians either but the West started
this you're basically saying be careful
what you wish for you want Putin out of
there who's next in line
absolutely and for everybody that was
like Rush Trump and Russia and all the
Russia none of this would have been
happening if Trump was in so you're
absolutely congratulations for voting
for violence because this is what you
get Alex you're saying that this guy's
even more hard-line anti-west anti-nato
than Putin her gogen is is five times
worse than Putin really how do you know
that like what kind of research have you
done pronouncing his name but I've been
studying them for 20 years I knew who
this guy was 20 years ago I mean I mean
I've watched I mean he's he's always
been there he's been Putin's right-hand
man since he was president before that I
mean they came up together in St
Petersburg uh and uh what can you tell
us about the the essence of the Wagner
group he heads this but what's the whole
purpose of these guys well let's let's
do this first and then that because
there's a key point I want to make here
or give me a pin all right I don't
remember to do it but if I don't forget
let me answer your question okay
thanks
um what is the Wagner group I'll do that
and then I'll do
um I forgot what I was gonna say was key
sorry
um so my brain works per gojin
you're asking what the Wagner group does
yes okay it was uh started uh 20 years
ago by Putin roughly uh as his own
private mercenary Army to kill people he
wanted killed inside Russia
with plausible deniability and then to
kill people around the world and to go
uh take over with mercenary forces uh in
the third world just like China and the
US doesn't take resources so they go
around a pillage uh and they uh also uh
assassinate people for Putin
and apparently they're currently in the
all over North Africa the Middle East
Syria they were the ones that helped
invade Crimea and they're all over
Ukraine right now they're all over
Ukraine and they've been one of the most
active forces and progojian has been
saying the last year and a half since it
started
I know the weapon systems and he's
proven he's a good military commander
and I've got military guys you know he
got out of prison that's like Moses
force your military you're out and a lot
of these are you know former Special
Forces got some of the best Russian
military they've got
and they're all saying the military is
losing on purpose we think they made a
deal with the west and they're going to
take out Putin he's been saying that for
a year uh and and so that's why I think
they may have tried to kill Putin and
blame pregogin because how does he think
with 25 000 troops if he can't take
Ukraine and he's only taken to some
cities how's he going to go take on the
Russians so they've got 10 times the
force Rob can you do me a favor just
pull up the WSU WS Chase story and let's
just read the whole thing so what what
is Wall Street Journal they just came
out they're fairly reasonable and in the
middle what's Wall Street Journal saying
let's just read this so
president Moon said Saturday he ordered
military to act against uh Wagner
parliamentary group that sees the
Russian stomach you've got that as
Wagner columns uh move forward towards
Moscow Saturday they were attacked by
Russian aircraft
in the vorage
region some 300 miles south of the
capital videos from the area show the
city main fuel Depot Ablaze a uh uh k-52
helicopter destroying a vehicle and
another helicopter narrowingly escaping
a Wagner anti-craft missile a Russian
plane was also shot down okay the crisis
unfolding in Russia represents the most
serious challenge to Putin's 20-year
23-year rule a direct consequence of the
strains put on Russia's society and
Armed Forces by the war that he
Unleashed against Ukraine in February of
last year if the Wagner group
Insurrection isn't put down swiftly The
Strife could significantly undermine
Russia's front-line troops in Ukraine
just as Kiev carries out a
western-backed offensive to Crime
occupied lands the uprising wasn't
already emerging Russia Society
challenges Putin's strategy of wagon a
long war against Ukraine okay so that's
not saying anything
is saying
we're we we've withdrawn because our
half our troops died to uh you know
western edge of Russia they began to
bomb us this morning we are not
advancing this is a lie and see notice
the footage they say they have is a fuel
Depots and their base is getting blown
up so the military sees them as a threat
and it's taking them out but here's the
larger question that was gonna please
continue but I want your take on this
notice the timing of this what happened
in the last two months the ukrainians
launched their counter offensive two
months ago not two weeks ago in probes
then they launched their main attack and
not hundreds but but 10 like 400 or 500
I've watched the videos I spent days
searching and it's not duplicates the
Russians it takes three times the troops
and armor to take a position and you
know this for the military than it does
two two two two uh defend it so the
Russians got torn up going in but now
the ukrainians have got to go into their
defenses yep and so it got destroyed and
I've confirmed this from sources of the
military not just what was in the news
and even seeing in the midst okay the
offensive got destroyed most of the
equipment got destroyed uh like half of
it they've still got half the stuff that
was sent they're sending more but they
don't have troops to operate it because
you got to train them and so the
Russians just destroyed this
counter-offensive then magically it
kicks into gear for a coup against Putin
that's the next phase if they can't
drive them out and have that Victory
then next we get Putin and and so again
is the high command working with the
West to get rid of pagogian and Putin
and set up their new Russia system maybe
with the West maybe not we don't know
which group this is the timing of that
fits with the West with the Russian
system cutting off pagodian and Putin
because these guys are best friends now
I'm not saying that's what's happening
but you know Putin isn't sure and and so
right now he's like okay we're going to
get pregogin but I think Putin's main
issue is going to be his own military
and his own system or maybe he's killing
his best friend and does seem as a
threat we don't know but the Russian uh
defense just annihilated the ukrainians
in the last two months so why is this
coming now the West would normally go to
this next
but this is an overthrowing Saddam by
buying office generals this is Russia
and this is dangerous as hell and and
this is the same week too that we
accidentally sent them what 6.2 billion
dollars the Pentagon was like absolutely
whoops we sent uh Ukraine all this 200
billion's really been sent over the last
couple years and guaranteed half that's
coming right back to the global 100 guy
100 so here here's obviously it's too
early to tell what's really going on but
if you think about it those who are for
Ukraine this is a beautiful thing
because what happens when it's shown
that the country is divided that's an
easy easy way to come in and capitalize
off this is horrible for Russia this is
horrible now the ukrainians you know are
going to launch the next counter
offensive because they only use chapter
four yeah now the Russians don't know
what the hell's going on the Russian's
gonna have to withdraw some of the
troops from Ukraine to go fight this to
fight in Russia exactly so then who do
you think's really behind us it's the
West has the motive has the timing I'm
not saying it's that right now but now
we have 60 percent it's like a computer
sixty percent of the evidence with the
mode of the timing the history the
background How the West operates says
it's the west and as we get more data
I'm not going to like sit there and just
get data that I want to agree with if I
get more data showing that this is
what's really happening for Georgian
tried this and it's crazy That's a
classic Russian power play then I'll go
back to well now it's a 60 chance that
it's as we're being told but I'm just
keep taking data and usually as I take
that data then as it gets closer it's
almost always the analysis I had and
that's how real Intel stuff happens so
so what is the difference I mean this
you were saying happened to Yeltsin and
now you know they're on track for doing
it with him as well 23 years he's been
running it right we're talking about
since 2000 it's been Putin right and he
does look sick he really has thyroid
cancer yeah do you think so when you're
saying this could be you know
catastrophic
et cetera et cetera from the nuclear
standpoint the bottom line with this is
this is super destabilization with the
number one nuclear power in a war zone
this is just on a scale of one to ten
the this is like a 9.8 I mean this is
because why because why because they've
got because because if he retaliates
because if Putin's like I'm sick of it
and I'm going to retaliate at or Ukraine
or why exactly they have Iran
Corporation threat ladder that's got 43
stages pull up the Rand Corporation 43
stages of escalation
and and this came up with this in the
60s and it still followed globally as
Doctrine the Russians adopted this as
well and it's the stages of escalation
uh so it's the stages of military
escalation and there it is uh and and so
one of the reports they're always
updating it we're already at like staged
29. well when you get up you know and
any much more it's nuclear war it's
tactical then it's and it goes through
what both sides do and you've got a
dictator
strong man all this with nuclear weapons
all these forces battling him all this
craziness
what a Putin Falls what the whole thing
disintegrates then where'd all the nukes
go or what's Ukraine going to do and
then other power groups Poland's been
talking about grabbing part of Ukraine
that was always part of them I mean it's
just like World War II once this stuff
starts it just gets out of control the
only difference is like for for people
that hear that and sometimes they get
you know Panic oh my God is this going
to lead to World War Three is this the
the difference from my understanding the
difference between the access Putin has
to nuclear bombs versus the way we have
it he can't just press a button and
approve it there's got to be multiple
layers of approval that he has versus
the way we have it right
um
no no no that's not how it works okay if
you can pull up the nuclear protocol for
Russia it's a there is a different layer
of approval for him to choose to do
something like that look let's face it
from from in the last hundred years how
many times has the nuclear bomb been
dropped why shouldn't it okay yeah
yeah but if a guy with dirty bombs and
like little suitcase bombs and for a guy
that is but the point dying and a guy
that's dying is pretty much it looks
like he's gonna they're attacking the
cap and about to take him over why not
just be like you know what I'm going
down I'm going down well here's Neil why
do you think he just gave nukes to
Belarus that's his backup oh wow Rob is
that it
it says here following the American
pattern the unlock and launch
authorization codes held by the general
staff at their command centers can be
sent directly to individual weapons
commanders who would execute the launch
procedures the crews on board doc
submarines have demonstrated the ability
to fire while surfaced at peer side
within 9 to 15 minutes after receiving
the order the other alternative the
general staff could direct uh could
direct missile launches directly from
command centers in the Moscow vicinity
or alternative facilities throughout the
country but it doesn't say that Putin
could directly the the way they have it
is which I which I think that's the
right way to do it I I don't think a
nuclear call should be I think it's
dangerous that Biden has that crazy man
that doesn't know who he is could like
just say launch the web I I think we all
know he doesn't have that I think you
know I don't even know if his button
works the other day he was putting his
hand on his chest
about working I was at a I was a flight
security controller at Malmstrom Airport
Base Montana at a nuclear missile base
the there's two uh to launch a nuclear
weapon yeah there's so many stages Pat
and then it goes down to the miscelliers
who have to get authenticated no because
let me tell you what would happen if
they did a nuclear it would be it
wouldn't be what happened with Japan it
would be so many people involved it
would be back and forth the economy
drops 50 you know the market drops it so
it's over too many people are involved
to not allow this from happening and
that's right of a tactical weapon even
gets used the market dropped 50 yeah
that's what the analysts believe yeah
but the point is I'm not trying to be
Luma Doom I'm just saying Russia with
the biggest nuclear Arsenal in a civil
war with a major war on its border we've
got a crazy president I'm just saying I
see all these pieces people better be
concerned no no and by the way there's
some rumors right now on Twitter talking
about the fact that you know Putin's
left Moscow I don't know if you saw that
or not Putin no he did leave yeah yeah
Putin left Moscow where did he head to
he's got an armored train that they're
not sure if the train left Alex you know
what would be interesting right now how
closed captioning not available
what can the average person do to even
exclude that explain to the average
person what this means from 18 20
minutes to 18 minutes to 100 seconds to
midnight and back up to where it was in
1980 1990 so just get some context right
you'll have some images yeah
Dooms two minutes to midnight so
basically the the clock is getting
closer and closer and closer to closer
midnight means well it moves up and down
I go to 19 go to the early 1960s human
Missile Crisis
that was like they said was the worst uh
let's see when this three minutes 12
minutes
so two minutes so three minutes to
midnight is 1949. Two Minutes to
Midnight that's 1953.
uh does it go any further back or no Rob
that's it okay keep going up let's just
say go starting right after World War II
go keep going up keep going up so we got
seven minutes four minutes three minutes
six minutes nine minutes fourteen
minutes seven minutes ten minutes seven
minutes
five minutes six minutes five minutes
two minutes two minutes three minutes
three minutes keep going two minutes 100
seconds was 20 20 100 seconds 2021 it's
still the same thing 100 seconds
2022. so during covid and and does it
have it for today during covid
and now it's 100 seconds it's not
changed okay
I think that's some kind of article
There's an actual clock there's a press
release the point is that's their
feeling on I I would just say this moves
the clock towards it
as Doom's clock moved check to see Rob
if they're doing Doomsday
well well let me ask you guys this
question
um
if they get rid of Putin and they put a
less hard-line guy in will that embolden
the warmongers in DC to launch more crap
because they want to go to war with
China and I don't like China and I don't
like Gigi ping uh it's just like the
Chinese people but I mean I hate the
Thomas Chinese what they do and
everything but I mean they're really
trying to sell a war now with China this
is getting nuts
and if they are they're able to defeat
Russia by overthrowing Putin with a
bunch of intelligence operations I mean
this is just going to make them more
hungry well let's see what happens here
I want to transition into what happened
yesterday with Karina uh Korean if you
want to play this clip because this clip
was you know not a not a good day
because nobody was giving up typically
it would be you know somebody that will
come and maybe they'll do it one time
and everybody else will change because
it's getting a little bit too
uncomfortable this is probably the most
uncomfortable
I've seen her maybe ever okay if you
want to play this game what's the
reference this is that's not something I
want to say they're asking her uh about
uh Hunter's uh text about uh uh Chinese
businessman my father is right here with
me you better send this you better do
this and uh this is the because Kirby
just walked off before this but uh this
is her do you have the Kirby clip to
show before we go to this one I'll get
the Kirby clip after this okay so go
ahead and play this one here watch this
and secondly um
the president invited his son Hunter to
the state dinner last night I'm
wondering if you could take us into the
thinking and decision making of why the
president decided I'm just not going to
get into family discussions personal
family discussion as you know Hunter is
his son I'm just not going to get into
it if Hunter Biden wasn't the
president's son would he have invited
someone who had just reached a plea
agreement with Federal prosecutors a
couple of things again that's his son
it's a he's a family member it is not
uncommon for family members to attend
events at the White House you could look
at past presidents I'm sure you have so
that is not uncommon as it relates to
anything
related to uh to Hunter
from here yeah yeah
no I just called in somebody go ahead
yeah so but I mean so curly wouldn't
answer James's question though are you
going to answer the question not a
reasonable question to ask for the
president United States
shocked that they're asking in some sort
of uh coercive conversation for business
dealing by assignment is that something
I appreciate the question I believe
he has answered this question already
has dealt with this has uh made it very
clear I just don't have anything to
share outside of what my colleagues have
shared and so I would refer you to him
and the doj another question
what I can tell you is I know that my
colleague has dealt with this he uh
addressed this at the White House
Council I just don't have anything else
to share I just I just answered the
question thank you
Stephen Stephen I just answered the
question I just said I just this is it's
not up to you how I answer the question
I just answer the question by telling
you my colleagues at the White House
Council has dealt with this and I would
refer you another one coming
said from the White House Council so we
have it I would I would refer you to
them and they will share their statement
with you I love you your statements from
that Podium you've stated wow that the
president stands by his comment from the
2020 campaign that he never once
discussed his son's overseas business
dealings with his son and you stood at
that Podium and you reaffirmed that do
you stand by your reality what I will
say is nothing has changed nothing has
changed and I will leave it there
anything else I will refer you to the
White House counselor wait can I just
answered the question you asked you just
asked me
change I just told you no wonder trust
the White House another one coming
yeah Stephen Stephen I'm calling on your
colleague right now yo thank you to
follow up on my phone is there anything
that you can say with regard to no
matter who she goes and what the
president's son was alleging was the
president there or not
I would refer you to my colleagues yeah
zero no credibility and I refer you to
them okay but that's like Neil deGrasse
Tyson the president
I've had with the president again okay
pause it for a second and I want to
finish this let me see why this is
horrible let me tell you why this is
horrible here's why it's horrible
because okay flipping into what the same
thing happened with kellyanne you know
mcanany or Etc and said no the
difference is that was this is liberals
Republicans left right every single
outlet wants to know the same exact
thing and she keeps she keeps giving the
same answer matter of fact finish it up
real quick I want to watch the whole
thing almost done and then go to Kirby
right after that go ahead and then we'll
go to the 100 clip
have that conversation with the
president no did the president speak
with the attorney general at all I can't
I I cannot say uh if the president had
had a conversation with the attorney
general last night what I can refer you
to is the White House counsel's office
as it relates to the allegations they've
already addressed this this is something
for them to deal with I refer to the
Department of Justice on anything else
if you don't want to speak to the White
House counsel's office and there was
reporting earlier in the week that after
the plea agreement was reached by Hunter
Biden that the president felt relieved
that that part of it was behind him is
that true can you I can't speak to that
I cannot speak to them now go to Kirby
and then we'll watch the yeah go to
Kirby pathetic loser yeah watch this
year look how schmuck I hate this guy I
would punch him in the face if I could
house Ways and Means Committee yesterday
released documents their authenticity
nowhere challenged that included a July
2017 WhatsApp message
by Hunter Biden to Henry Zhao a Chinese
Communist Party official
which stated in its entirety and I quote
I am sitting here with my father and we
would like to understand why the
commitment made has not been fulfilled
tell the director that I would like to
resolve this now before it gets out of
hand and now means
if I get a call or text from anyone
involved in this other than you Zhang or
the chairman I will make certain that
between the man sitting next to me the
man every Mexican he knows and my
ability to forever hold a grudge that
you will regret not following my
direction I am sitting here waiting for
the call with my father unquote
so just a couple of questions about this
first does this not undermine uh the
president's claim during the 2020
campaign and the reaffirmations of that
claim by his two press secretaries since
then that he never once discussed his
son's overseas business dealings with
him no and I'm not going to comment
first yeah of course
James James let me just let me save you
some let me say let me say let me save
you some breath if you're going to ask
about this I am not addressed I don't I
know you do more than I'd like you to
have I am not going to address this
issue from this Podium
yeah look get the hell out of there you
rat thanks guys
look at her she's
is collapsing this is the collapse but
think about this
in fact there's never got a lot of
traction when the hunter Biden thing
came out like three years ago right
before the election we've we played the
audio you can find this where you can
type in Hunter bite and talks about his
Chinese spy handler he's like Dad I
haven't talked in three months so they
had a Chinese intelligence he's worth 25
million dollars he's giving us Millions
I think they may have gotten him we're
not in control of the Chinese Communists
they're what are we gonna do Daddy I
mean there's audio of him he saved audio
messages he sent his dad and it's got
like no attention at the time yeah I'm
telling you to pull these up so so
there's audio of stuff like this do you
know what CNN did yesterday too you know
CNN because they have to spin it right
that they said oh what are the dates
Hunter was on crack cocaine you can't
blame him from he probably made that up
because he was on crack cocaine
appropriate power recent video that's
come up for Hunter what's what's the
most recent thing that came up he was
flipping out yesterday about 10 for the
big guy he was The Bag Man for his dad
yep and then that's the whole point he's
the most Untouchable crackhead on the
planet you know that he could do crack
have videos with underage girls have you
seen his dad say when he was a Senator
if you're black you get caught with
cocaine you get five years in jail it's
right there yeah oh you got to play this
yo this is yeah this is Mr not racist
for all you people that voted for him
look at him if you have a
piece of
crack cocaine
no bigger than this quarter that I'm
holding in my hand one quarter of one
dollar look at the presidency we passed
the law through the leadership of
Senator Thurman and myself and others a
law that says you're caught with that
crap you go to jail
for five years you get no probation you
get nothing other than five years in
jail unless you're my son who doesn't
have a choice under our forfeiture
statutes you can the government can take
everything you owned everything from
your car to your house your bank account
not merely what they confiscate in terms
of the dollars from the trees
they can take everything I don't care
why they become a sociopath we have an
obligation to recording them off from
the rest of society they are in jail
away from my mother away from my mother
our family so I don't want to ask
what made them do this they must be
taken off the street
[Music]
rules for thee and not for me
meanwhile he's the no between with a
Chinese Communist yeah I mean I mean
take swallows well take Feinstein they
all had like Chinese he was Danny Fang
thing or what was her name these are
operatives either operations flies they
were dating spies bro it's unbelievable
but but you know you know what I I gotta
say credit for guys we're making
progress because people are asking the
question now this leads me to the next
question with you Alex
is
okay so did you see Newsom on Hannity
did you see how we did I didn't I think
he did very well I I think American
Psycho Slickers
very very well if you're a Democrat if
you're a Democrat
Newsome was ten times more presidential
than Biden was and it's not even close
Okay so for him to have the audacity to
go to Fox's best today which is Hannity
today not Tucker but Fox's best today
Hannity he goes and sits with them and
he hangs and he pushes back with Hannity
so from your perspective you know you
made a comment earlier about Newsom is
this uh the reason why these guys are
asking the question are they kind of
trying to Corner Biden for him to step
out so Newson can go run is it going to
be a Newsome DeSantis Newsom Trump what
is this going to happen here Patrick I'm
so glad you brought that up because I
have this problem with not hitting the
most obvious thing you're absolutely
right that's it
they're getting ready to take out the
garbage with Biden I think they'll
probably kill him or he'll die in a
sleeper he'll fall down some stairs fall
downstairs or or be you know drugged or
whatever or at least be in a coma very
soon and I've got very high level
sources that are you got people dug in
the Democratic party Roger Stone's
totally dialed in he was on my show
yesterday and he said they're crazy
enough that they're thinking this is
what Democrats are saying right now okay
Big Mike Michelle Obama and uh and then
VP news some or Newsom but uh Obama is
he's the real president right now you
know third term I'm elected we have a
video uh uh he he's now coming back out
and saying oh I'm involved now so yeah
they're getting ready to get rid of
Biden that's the only reason those
reporters are all on a leash none of
them ever ask a question for the two and
a half years suddenly they're all
attacking yep it's because they've been
let off the leash because Biden was
supposed to like he said right before he
won the election remember he said well
if I don't do what I'm told I'll
probably just develop some weird disease
and and resign remember that quote yep
he said it multiple times letting them
know hey I'm your man well that is he
still his brain was still there remember
the deals then but according to Roger
Stone and other sources and Roger's Dead
on he's hangs out with he talks to some
of the high level Democrats uh Jill
Biden is telling him don't leave she
likes the power and he's told them F off
in fact now he's not even following
Obama's orders do you think so oh no I
mean like like oh yeah oh yeah Jill's in
charge Jill's in charge because he
didn't know who he is I mean she
literally remember he walked out of the
wild he said my butt's been wiped I was
told by the NYPD and Secret Service a
year and a half ago when he went
remember he kept showing up late and
changing clothes like three times that
when he gets mad when he goes in these
weird
because they get him on speed and much
stuff to roll him out and hope it's okay
and it's not now but when he gets mad he
he takes a big dump in his drawers and
I'm serious okay you've got him saying
my butt's been wiped so that goes Alex
he he said he did say it I've seen can
we fact check so Alex claimed that he
said that he would develop Biden said
that he would develop some sort of
cognitive disease and resign if he
didn't follow the place and here's the
clip let's see but all kidding aside the
first lady to be told me she holds them
for you yes she does but not with she's
speaking she and Kamala become friends
but all kidding aside it's it's a matter
of the thing we are simpatico on our
philosophy of government and simpatico
on how we want to attach approach these
issues that we're facing and so I don't
have and when we disagree it'll be just
like so far it's been just like Moroccan
I did it's in private she'll say I think
we should do ABC or D and I'll say I
don't I like a I don't like B and C and
let's go okay but and I like I told
Barack if if I reach something where
there's a a fundamental disagreement we
have based on a moral principle I'll uh
I'll I'll I'll I'll I'll I'll develop
some disease and say I have to resign
um we don't have that I'm we haven't and
we discussed it when it's your face our
views yeah and Alex have you ever
because he said this multiple times but
look how much he's declined in three
years oh that's I mean he's a little
daughter but he's that's a I mean he's
gone yeah but he wasn't even there you
know what milk kind of tastes a little
better but then later it's like cottage
cheese and just you open ugh I mean he's
now a rotting carton of milk and Alex
how many times have you heard him say
the president of the United States hey I
I can't I gotta get out of here they
told me I can't do this or they told me
I can't say that no but but he found
that club I forgot about there's another
one where he says look I'm a you know if
I'm not doing what they want I'll just
get a disease and resign he said it at
least twice so there's he said it in the
current context like a year ago or
something so is this it or no this is
the clip where he says the white
president talks about his butt because
[Music]
the question is Newsom DeSantis Newsom
Trump Biden Trump what's going to end up
happening
I mean Trump was uh five six points
ahead of Biden he got indicted and then
now he's like 15 to 20 on Saturday polls
it's a spectrum um he's he in a in a
bunch of national polls of Republican
voters he is 57 on the low to 72 points
ahead I mean the whole field Chris
Christie all of them uh uh your Governor
here to Santa's they are getting 30 35
points
and then Trump gets all around so and
the more they indict him like I remember
when they indicted him again a few weeks
ago they go well the the new the New
York indictment of Alvin Bragg that made
him go up but this time people are going
to turn on him no he went up like five
ten more points after that so I guess if
they indict him like 18 more times
they'll have like 99 with Republicans I
mean people know that they're they're
telling them like like
you got a dog it's a sweet dog but he
was a Labrador Retriever you start
trying to take something away from him
it's going to tug a war with you and
they're telling you can't have Trump
can't have Trump and it's just the more
they do it the people are getting madder
and matter like I want this I want this
and and uh it's just insane so it's the
Unstoppable object
a movable object a movable object comes
into contact with the establ force and
it just explodes and so I mean they
intend to indict him on January 6 for
the electors they're trying to cook it
up this is a 20-page article three days
ago Washington post that I commanded the
attack on the capital of trump
completely insane uh didn't even talk to
Trump for like a year before that uh
tried to stop people going to the
capital when I got there we had a whole
stage booked with the booked with uh
the uh Capitol Police and everything for
him on the northeast corner and we get
there there's no police no one they just
left us high and drive and set us up now
they have Congressional reports that
uh D.C police were the ones dressed up
breaking in and then getting the idiots
to going behind them I mean Congressmen
have said that
Congressman has seen that they're now
releasing the footage of the DC are they
going to succeed are they going to
succeed to prevent him from running
I mean they're succeeding in a civil war
and right now in Russia I mean yeah the
globalist hijacked the most powerful
country in the world with all our
Ingenuity and all our money and all our
power and the world's in deep trouble um
and again it's not like I'm saying China
or Russia are good either it's just it's
just a monstrous situation and if people
don't get serious to get out of their
comfort zones uh yeah I think they'll I
mean I think they're going to demonize
him and die him and die him and die him
and Dot him and then I I think they'll
blow his airplane up I really at a gut
level believe they're gonna kill Trump
who's this Trump uh I mean I mean I
believe the Deep State establishment
will murder him I mean I believe he's
going to steadfast go through all this
uh he'll be
he'll be 30 points ahead in the
primaries nothing's going to stop him
and then they just uh you know he dies
of a heart attack which is they poison
they blow his airplane up and I think
and Trump by the way he's talked to
Roger and others and said I'm ready to
die I'm committed I'm going all the way
so you think you think if they you know
you're saying they're gonna do that they
would have already done it like why
haven't they already done it because
that turns him into a martyr and they
and they'd rather assassinate the person
they saw how well JFK did to him I mean
this will be 50 I mean look
they are not the higher-ups of some of
their smarter ones are not stupid
they're like if we if we kill him it'll
cause way bigger problems down the road
don't do it but before they let him get
in charge and prosecute him which Trump
said he will he goes I'm getting in I'm
gonna I'll be destroyed and you'll be
destroyed with me or they'll be
destroyed it's a death battle this isn't
like some cage fight with Zuckerberg and
everybody's like oh Zuckerberg and Elon
musk's biggest thing ever yeah great two
modern Emperors Tech Titans when Rome
was collapsing they had Emperors as
Gladiators now the Moody Gladiators
actually get a composite of a bunch of
true stories that really happened and
the whole point is well we're all
watching this stupid stuff in the
submarine and the Gladiators literally
the president who I I believe won the
election not supposed to say that oh you
know he he barely lost
um Trump
now to have them put him in jail so he
can't vote for him or whatever it's just
not going to fly it's not going to
happen and so but at the same time you
saw what Comey other said on TV well
whatever we do we got to stop him he
can't be allowed in because he'll put us
in prison and remember you can pull this
clip Up Biden said
um last December like December 13th I
was I put the club last week on my show
he said repeatedly Biden says we will
not allow Trump to be president again
and he says we'll use whatever we have
to with law enforcement the Constitution
to make sure he's not president and he
just laughs arrogantly he's like people
like hey what about Hunter he's like you
know it's just it's it's lunacy uh but
but time's running out so they still
have the power they're still the
executive in control
so if you're the guy with the Doomsday
button you can hit it you think you win
it you blow yourself up at the same time
so they will they've already destroyed
themselves the only question is can they
take us with them Alex what do you say
about some of the people that are saying
uh the left is too calm during all this
and they're gonna they're planning
something let's just say into during the
election year another pandemic is
probably going to hit which they've been
warning us about that even the who by
there he said it Biden said and you can
find that Rob and I quote there's going
to be a second pandemic it's like he's a
psychic uh something there's an internet
apocalypse they're talking about or even
like a a staged Alien Invasion do you
know do you feel like something well you
just said it other than that's a great
question how do they stop Trump yep he
dies into sleep as they poison him where
he naturally dies which I don't think
will happen they got as strong as a
horse Scottish uh you know German blood
he's got going there and then
um so there's that
and absolutely a stock market crash an
EMP that knocks out the power for a few
months oh we can't have it right now
another virus through the mailing things
like the U.N says imminent virus coming
I think there yeah there's a lot of ways
for them to skin the cat but I'm telling
you these indictments aren't working
they're not so so so you're saying based
on what you're saying you're saying it's
still going to be Newsome Trump is that
what you're saying like come next year
newsom's the serious candidate and who
they now admit you see them getting on a
deep freeze rolling him out getting him
ready
but they're thinking about the Wild Card
uh Obama has warned warmed into some and
right now there's discussions this is
this is real there's discussions of
Michelle Obama as the president and
Newsome or should it be Newsome
president Michelle Obama vice president
that would be by the way that's going to
be tough to be it's a Powerhouse that's
going to be tough to be so what do you
think about the incredible men what are
your thoughts on descent
Alex can I can I just I'm just joking
Joan Rivers made a joke about it too she
did yeah she died two weeks later what
do you think about the Santas what are
your thoughts on the Santas I think the
Sanders when he was running his own show
a few months six months ago was
heartfelt doing great things standing up
to stuff really doing a great job for
Florida then he started again with the
Republican strategist Karl Rove and Jeb
Bush and they're now advising him now
he's following a script and he's not
being authentic and as soon as they
indicted Trump trump went you know 30
points ahead of him uh so I mean the
Santa seems to know he's being Kamikaze
into Trump and that the system knows
he's not going to beat him uh and
they're not going to let the Santa
uh and so DeSantis needs to understand
that he should get behind Trump uh and
uh reprieve himself and Trump's not
perfect but now they're trying to take
my right to vote for him and the fact
that he's got such balls and doing this
I would be a coward because they'd come
after me because of the support I've
been told leave stop supporting Trump
and all your problems will stop I mean
I've been told that in mediations okay
not supposed to talk about that but I
mean it's literally stop this dude back
off and we'll leave you alone or you're
done I'm like hey at a certain point I
can't just roll over and be a coward so
you've made me be all in for Trump I
mean I just can't do it as a man I can't
be told you know I mean down in Texas
where the mafia never did too well
because you tell them to come tell about
somebody there I'm gonna take over your
business guy just pulls a gun out you
know shoot you you may see more guys get
me later that's great my kin folks are
coming for you so I just can't I just I
just it's not like a macho thing I just
can't I can't be pushed around I'm I'm
gonna die then that's okay but the point
is you're gonna die too at a certain
point these guys got to figure out
you'll fire your musket but I'll run you
through the Iron Maidens you know first
opening line of the of the trooper
you'll fire a musket but I'll run you
through so Alex let me let me kind of
bring this in for a second
um you've made some opinions some claims
some thoughts some jokes some hyperbole
all that
um my opinion and then I'm gonna ask it
too I don't think Barack Obama is
running the country right now my opinion
I don't think Michelle Obama is a man I
don't think she was ever a man my
opinion
um I don't think Gavin Newsom is gonna
be that dude that's running he has done
nothing but endorse Biden okay I'm going
somewhere with this right at the same
time I don't think they're gonna kill
Trump I think he's gonna be that dude on
stage uh I think he's going to probably
be the nominee we'll see what happens
with the Santas we'll see what happens I
I don't think he's gonna get killed in
his sleep I'm just you know how you know
how you say sometimes you just gotta
face reality and see what's in front of
your face I think at the end of the day
it's going to be a Biden Trump
presidential debate and then here's my
question don't you want that
don't yes I'd rather that be
entertaining okay that's my freaking
Point don't you want that if Biden is as
nuts lost delusional as people say don't
you want Trump to expose that on a
national stage and prove everybody right
but of course but I don't and they make
us a sick joke let him debate a
vegetable uh and then still steal it
from him no no no no because they're
going to debate and then the world is
going to see whether or not Biden is
competent or not because you could say
whatever you want about Trump he hasn't
lost the step he still has energy he's
still there whether you think he's a
criminal or you think he's a hero and a
deity he hasn't lost a step Biden
clearly has but don't you want that
don't you want that basically that
rematch to basically 100 rather than you
want well let me just tell you this and
I've said this before it came out and he
said it on Joe Rogan show he's where the
CIO killed him they killed his dad and
his Uncle Robert F Kennedy Jr doesn't
want to give speeches out in the public
now because he knows I mean that's real
and let me tell you Trump knows there's
plans to kill him and if they get some
crazy to do it impossible ability they
will they shot Ronald Reagan and then
Hinckley Juniors you know was having
dinner with with the bushes in Colorado
three days before I mean this is serious
looking up a Timber post so so this is
Rob look it up did you hear what he said
was it dumb Republic Junior well it was
it was it was hinckley's uh brother and
dad were having dinner but he was also
best friends with the bushes CIA uh uh
hinckley's having dinner with uh Bush's
week of Reagan Big Shot anyways
they let him out of prison recently what
I'm getting at here is that this is from
real politicos this is from Roger Stone
okay I mean the guy got Trump to run
okay and what I'm telling you is uh is
that
is that they say they're they sell these
puff pieces about Michelle Obama uh and
and you know Gavin news and the rest of
it
Biden could die at any time let me just
fall over so I'm telling what real
people are telling me it doesn't mean
they're totally right okay and and you
know as for Michelle Obama of course
Michelle Obama is a beautiful woman and
of course I'm serious when I say this of
course Joan Rivers was just joking maybe
she was on Robert's Club said it and
then she died what two weeks later
because she was [__] 88 years old
well the timing is perfect timing is
perfect but can I say one thing okay
Alex Jones you've been called the
conspiracy theorist uh meet your master
yeah right there congratulations well
you were you just said that Obama Obama
you don't think Obama is one of the
country this was Obama on Stephen
Colbert the leftist hack show uh two
years ago can you play play what he said
about the presidency go ahead Ron what
you know now do you wish like you had a
sec a third term be right back two
seconds again and I I used to say
you know what if if I could make an
arrangement where
um I had a I had a stand-in a front man
or front woman and they had an earpiece
in and I was just in my basement sweats
and looking through the stuff and that I
could sort of deliver the lines but
somebody else was uh doing all the
talking and the ceremony I'd be fine
with that I'd be totally fine with
Vinnie as a comedian okay as a
professional comedian the number one
Assyrian comedian in the world yeah you
have the ability to decipher satire
joking yeah do you think he was actually
coming out and saying yes this is my
third term come on man well Adam I think
there's a little truth and and
everything especially as a comedian but
you let's just be honest with each other
do you actually think that Joe Biden
right now is actually making the
decisions and tweeting and doing
everything that he's doing be honest
with me I think he has a team around him
that is helping him make the decision
okay making decisions have you ever
heard in your life a president say oh I
can't do this because they told me that
I can't speak or they don't
of course I'd like to see that could you
find that I'm just telling you they are
why do you think here's the key is just
what Patrick said earlier
why do you think they're allowing
everybody to attack Biden now when they
covered it all up before because now
they want him to step down the Democrat
system is telling him step down and they
can create all this new energy and about
who it's going to be that they're
telling him well we're going to find out
if he actually is the nominee because
then that will be the inaccurate I mean
you know and I'm not bragging some of
you guys have dinner with high power
people talk to everybody too okay we
have dinner guys like you tell me what
I'm saying is this is directly from
inside the Trump camp at the highest
levels and directly from inside the
Democratic party so they they do not
want Biden they are seriously talking
about this as they should yeah
I'm not making a prediction I'm not
making a prediction I'm saying they
don't like what's going on no what he
does Alex of course his approval ratings
are in the doghouse he's 80 [__]
something years old of course they don't
want him to run okay but he's making a
decision to run I mean he's not making
any decisions let's be honest well but
it shows that even though he is a
vegetable he wants power kind of like
Yeltsin didn't want to leave and it's
the same thing there's power struggles
and power struggles are dangerous the
differences Boris Yeltsin was when his
like early 60s at that point I want to
say in in Russia
there we should only drink three
next question next next question here
Twitter why are you why are you not back
on Twitter I saw you know obviously
Roger storms back on Twitter you got
Trump's back on Twitter you got OJ's on
Twitter you got the kremlins on Twitter
you got the the leader
why are you why is Elon I mean Tates got
back on Twitter you know there's not a
lot of difference between what you say
versus what's up that's the key and I
think Tate should be on there so he can
defend himself I mean everybody well why
are you not on well it's a digital
utility
I'll answer that question but yes Andrew
Tate is a charge which with no evidence
as they've seen of of sex trafficking
raping women with no evidence
okay so he deserves to be on Twitter
Elon Musk will not let me on there
because he says I questioned whether a
mass shooting happened or not now I
never did the stuff they said I never
sent people people's houses I never peed
on graves but they were allowed to say
that in court because I was defaulted
they can say whatever they wanted and
and you know great folks love them to
death and and and and I pray you know
pray for him seriously
um that said
um he understands that I was demonized
let me explain this this is Keem
it came out in Congress at U.S
intelligence agencies were running the
censorship running the surveillance
running the control uh in the in the
2016 but they failed and then in 2020
they were in control of 2022 they were
successful that's in like three day long
earrings all of it I was picked out as a
populist to destroy my movement but it
was bigger than me to be able to shut
everybody else down and so this is not
an exaggeration I get Google Alerts and
I don't even follow them anymore because
it's too much there were some days in
the last five years where it would say
10 000 Google Alerts okay and then and
and 10 would be this woman named Alex
Jones is a big BBC lady she's popular
host if she has like a baby or something
some days like okay a third of that
shirt thank God it's not on me but I'm
talking most days it'll be a thousand
hits okay because they put one AP
article out and be putting every
newspaper around the country
so so some days it'd be twenty thirty
thousand so there was thousands of TV
programs they would put a report out and
it would be on ABC NBC CBS uh all of the
local stations I would routinely turn on
the local Spectrum channel to see the
weather and routinely it was me being
attacked on the local Time Warner owns
you know that 24-hour Cable in Austin
run by Time Warner it's like local CNN
that was not about me
that was about speech is bad here's this
horrible person this horrible things to
you know mass shooting Dead's kids just
dead kids dead kids mass shooting dead
kids take your guns take your speech
take this guy as a monster because that
was the art type of what they want to
destroy
Elon is playing 3D chess he really is
Trump isn't and Trump's a great guy but
elon's smarter when it really comes to
full spectrum stuff Elon knows they
charged up this giant battery of
hundreds of thousands of syndicated
articles because you know one gets out a
thousand times or more I mean we're
talking thousands of original articles
thousands of original shows I mean I've
been on PBS that I know of like 50 times
these I mean just program program just
you know Nova blabbing just everything
just every channel help NPR every day
charge me up as the Antichrist and to
put all this energy into how I'm the
worst person in the world what's
demonizing the people in Independent
Media so they can then use me later and
go oh look Alex Jones likes RFK oh look
Alex Jones says Peter Hotes is bad too
to always say like oh he doesn't like
Biden so the devil doesn't like body he
must be good it wasn't about me it was
about making me this image that they
stole my identity to own and control so
Elon knows I'm this charged up bomb with
this big hand grenade so he can free the
captives it already took half his
advertising he's barely hanging on
they're coming in with him with the esgs
as you said last night he may not win
this if he brings me on they can go look
he brought Satan on so he can free
everybody but me the Taliban everybody
else that's fine I kind of and I
understand it and I'm not I'm being
honest here now that I'm more
sophisticated I understand that you know
it's like Joe Rogan loves me we hang out
all this stuff and he's like yeah no I
can do all this stuff and expose the New
World Order and win and still get
criticized but hang on I have you come
say it then it's destructive
so so I understand Robert F Kennedy same
thing you know and so I understand and
it's great Robert F Kennedy is Alex
Jones now Joe Rogan is Alex Jones now
that was always my goal they're not me
they now see the same perspective
they're not questioning they now are
curious they now are studying they're
going to find the same thing I found and
more and so fine Robert F Kennedy Jr
won't come on Joe Rogan fine all that so
we go get dinner that's what I care
about hang out with this great Comedy
Club he's my friend that's what matters
in 25 years and so that's what this is
all about is winning and defeating these
people so I'm owning that I am the black
sheep and the and that the real devil
says the real devil says I'm the devil
what's that tell you I'm just a regular
guy that loves Freedom that discovered
all this stuff growing up around it and
I care and so that's it uh and so it's a
great question why am I on Twitter
there's your answer it takes the time
nobody ever shuts up for me
shut up for you
promise you're gonna come
on let me tell you you know uh I think I
think you need to be on there especially
the way elon's got it
uh I think uh I don't know why he hasn't
I don't even know if he's been asked the
question why has has anything oh he came
out and said I deserve to be murdered
who said that Elon Musk Elon Musk said I
should be murdered for what I did
oh about Sandy Hook yeah he said he said
he said you know what Alex Jones did
attacking those people when their
children died is the worst thing on
Earth not being Taliban not sex driving
and that's all for I mean seriously he
said Alex Jones is the worst I will
never reinstate him it would be as
Christ said he should have a stone tied
around his neck and Throne of the ocean
he said those words Elon Musk he tweeted
on him tweeted it child let me look at
that go a little up there yeah there you
go my firstborn child
that in my arms I felt this last
heartbeat I have no mercy for anyone who
would use the death of children for game
politics or fame interesting but then he
went on to say
for Alex Jones
before he bought Twitter
uh no that's right when he got it here
here go back up he said
there's another tweet where he says he
quoted Christ he said it'd be better for
him to have a millstone he he deserves
to have a millstone tied around his neck
wow
well you have you have high praise for
Elon you just said that he's a way
smarter than a trumpet right what he did
to him he's like you're right he's Satan
I won't bring him back I don't bring
everybody he just played their game
that's 3D chess I love it
man I couldn't I think thank you Elon
beautiful job who do you who do you put
in
in the in the in the class of people
that are fighting for Freedom whether
you say tucker whether you say Elon
whether you say these names who would
you put in that category who else would
you put in that category I mean we got
Rogan we got Elon we got who else would
you put in that well I got mad at Joe
Rogan five years ago six years ago
because I've known Joe uh you know since
since for 25 years I mean before he was
doing Fear Factor right he's starting
UFC he'd done news radio and we've
partied I mean we have uh We've like
you've seen the movie uh hangover yeah
well you've actually done that
like uh you know uh I don't it's like
the most interesting man in the world I
don't often do drugs but when I do is
literally so me and Joe have uh we have
done some stuff
I love Joe and I always thinking about
it people like why do you love that Joe
Rogan he's a smart yeah I told people 20
years ago I said that guy is super smart
because he let me tell you that guy he
sits there and plays Dumb and does all
that stuff and it's all calculated and
and uh he's a good guy he knows all this
stuff we talk every day I mean you know
they they get mad at him about that we
text constantly you know every day and
we send people articles and stuff he
just and that's why I got mad at him
when he was kind of going to liberals
about six years ago and kind of playing
games they were kind of recruiting him
and and I was just like Joe knock it off
stop you know about all this and then he
got more hardcore again and he went the
right direction and then they did the
lockdowns he said screw these people
it's all true I'm going after him and
now they've got Alex Jones that's that's
more controlled uh I mean I'm more
controlling himself not controlled by
them they got Alice shows 2.0 you got
Tucker Carl so they mess with him Alex
Jones 2.0 Joe Rogan Alex shows your
point I could just all he wants Victory
and I just I mean I'm actually proud of
the fact that uh I've Been instrumental
in waking up Joe Rogan you know he
listened to my show a lot 20 something
years ago he called in on my show on 9
11. and said it's irresponsible Alex
you're saying the US government blew the
buildings up I saw them blow it up I saw
the local news say we're going to blow
up building seven it was on the news
that day the back then stuff wasn't
archived so it wasn't until four years
later all the news put their archives
online when when when storage got better
and you could pull up building seven you
know we we're gonna blow up building
seven and we watch it come down it's on
the CBS News ABC News CNN we're going to
pull it that's a Larry Silverstein said
later on PBS you said he blew it up so
so Joe you know used to call me up and
go hey man I mean he really he knew I
meant what I was saying but he just
wouldn't believe how bad it was and then
about
I'd say by about 18 years ago he was
really awake sort of studying it and
they just couldn't he didn't want to
believe it anymore and then he kind of
got out of it about 10 years ago
he kind of did some shows debunking
conspiracies a TV show that he that kind
of turned into the dark side for a while
and then I started getting in his face
about her calling him up and stuff and
saying hey man you're not you're not
stupid you know you know you're I'm uh I
told him I said you're you know I'm
really admire you I know he's a great
guy I said you're a punk you're acting
like a punk and and I said if you keep
doing it I'm gonna go in there and start
attacking your ass and then uh and then
we kind of went back and forth and stuff
so I went crazy and I went too far and I
apologize to Joe but I mean now I'm just
so proud of him Alex let me read you one
quote from Rogan I mean there's tons out
there but um to kind of sing your praise
here he said this was he's actually
speaking with Lex Friedman he goes
people think he's hilarious you know
it's [__] up what happened with Sandy
Hook and all that but here's the deal
with Alex Jones he's right more often
than he's wrong and he basically gave
you praise that like you know people
here let me let me let me kind of give
you another thing you ever hear what
Dave chappella said about when people
call people crazy he was sitting he was
sitting there with um The Screen Actors
Guild Guy the one guy
and he goes
um he's talking about when Martin
Lawrence was going crazy in Blue Streak
and all that you know the term crazy
it's here's the thing when you call
somebody crazy it's dismissive
right you're basically oh he's crazy
dismiss it right and it's basically
saying I don't understand that guy is
just crazy he said I'm not gonna debate
you that's what it is it's a dismissive
thing the thing is that these people are
not crazy they're actually very strong
so when you hear Rogan defend you even
though that you've made some wrong
decisions you've actually owned up to
your wrong decisions when you hear
people say oh he's just freaking crazy
you're not crazy you have strong
opinions and
you believe what you say so
when you hear Rogan defend you when you
hear people call you crazy how do you
process all that are you crazy no I'm
not crazy uh and I'm listening to your
great question and I can go 10 hours my
ride has an event they've got to get to
they're trying to make me leave so let's
just wrap up in five minutes but I want
to come back anytime and I want to
invite you guys to fly to Austin and do
a show with me and you can you can you
can host out of there we got a bunch of
students we can take my Logos off
everything we can put yours up because
this facility is awesome I love
broadcasting from a vault look I am
crazy
[Laughter]
sir no but I mean everybody's crazy yeah
and anybody that tells you you're not
crazy is crazy is even crazier uh and so
um this is a crazy life on a weird
planet with all this fantastic stuff
we're trying to figure it all out uh and
I and I and I kind of got crazy when I
discovered all this stuff where I got to
where I thought everything was a
conspiracy and it's not a lot of times
it's just an aptitude or it's weirdness
uh but the globalists are trying to get
control of the esgs and the computers
and AI because they do want to control
it and so and they've got the most
control of anybody
and I think the people should start
having control about the choices we make
and what we do and that's why
bycotting what you guys do and support
the show because it was popular the day
you launched it and I watched a lot but
I mean the last few years and now you
can see when something blows up it was
like boom but that's now it's like
exponential so it grows from here to
here the first couple years it goes like
this then it goes 500 feet in the air
and we're you're now in that you know
now you can see that trajectory and I'm
not kissing your ass you can see it it's
exploding and it's a good show it
deserves it and it's one of the best
podcasts out there
and so I mean people need to support
what you're doing they need to support
Free Speech they need to know that it
takes courage to have Alex Jones on and
a lot of wimps don't do it uh and so
we're all big boys and girls we should
be able to actually hear what somebody
says I mean they used to interview you
know people like
Charlie Manson doesn't mean you agree
with Charlie Manson I'm not Charlie
Manson my point is we need to really
hear what somebody has to say and the
worst part about being de-platform
that's to let my hardcore great audience
listen every day at infowars.com and
on some radio stations around the
country other citizens people can find
it there but the biggest thing is they
can then misrepresent including uh deep
fakes I've had a bunch of deep fakes
done on me oh I tell you this talk
across the story real quick I've had
deep fakes done on me and the guys it's
online look up Alex Jones uh Tucker
Carlson defect and play it and uh and
I've just talked to him that day so I
get another call and then the CPA
meeting and uh
but I'll tell this story in a second the
point is is that is that
you don't get to respond on Facebook
Twitter Instagram CNN you know the old
days you can attack the New York Times
They call you no there's no it's all one
way
so you're reading the New York Times
saying he's a white supremacist and I
mean I'm not I don't want to get in to
talk about my family all this kind of
stuff but we're the opposite of that
okay and it's it's very you know the
White Stripes made a big deal about it
like I married a lady whose mother's
Jewish which actually makes her Jewish I
got three kids that that see themselves
Just As Americans and they're like are
we Jewish are we Christian because we're
Christian and we like you know that's
breaking news right there but the kids
are Jewish but the point is the white
supremacists well I've said this many
times are literally tell me how they
want to kill my family all the time so
I've experienced I get to be called a
white supremacist in the New York Times
for no evidence yeah and then meanwhile
you know my kids I guess technically
could you know commit a crime and run to
Israel the point is the point is the
point is whatever the point is is I'm
not ashamed of that but then at the same
time I talked about it years ago and
made all the Nazis come after me like
wow this is what it's like to like
associated with the Jews people really
want to kill you this is actually this
sucks this is wrong so but then the
media calls you white supremacy it's
just like I'm a white supremist and I'm
the white supremacist go look at white
supremacist websites I mean they hate me
more than almost anybody because I won't
make it all about you know hating Jews
or any other group all day I want to get
everybody for freedom and win so I'm
sitting there about a month ago or
that's five six weeks ago in a CPA
meeting at like five o'clock
I just actually talked to Tucker that
day
uh and
all of a sudden it was because he'd just
been fired you know a few weeks before
and uh all of a sudden hey it's Tucker
can you talk and it by the way they
spoofed his number and the guy went
online and bragged about all this so so
so he's the numbers Tucker Carl's number
so he had to get that number
this is it that's it oh this is fit I
mean I play the clip I mean I don't know
this is it I'm not gonna play it on the
show go ahead
one of the most bizarre things that ever
happened to me in my life happened
yesterday afternoon at about 5 45. I was
sitting in an accounting meeting oh
you're explaining it here I mean the guy
you hit pause in an office go to Twitter
uh
type in Alex Tucker Carlson uh what's it
called his Twitter
it's called what's it called what's it
called when they do that it's a deep
fake Tucker Carlson Alex Jones deep fake
so so the point is it's Tucker Carlson's
voice and they have his number so it
shows up and he goes are you all right
and I said yeah he goes well I want to
you know do all these sexual things to
you and I go okay this is not Tucker
this is AI and then
you have to play this
can you find it or no please it was all
over the news type it into Google type
in uh Alex Jones Tucker Carlson deep
fake or Prank Caller AI uh deep fakes
Tucker Carlson
now there it is they're the ceiling
Yahoo news
so and then I called Tucker and he goes
yeah man there's a lot more stuff than
that going on this is horrible and then
they discovered who he was before he
came did you play it on that tweet that
you played on that video or no or you
didn't play no that's the video the guy
that did it
but it came out later and then it was
another Burger because he said oh I got
this long conversation I faked Jones out
no I go this isn't Tucker this is an AI
like 20 like 10 seconds in and then he
hangs up so sympathy but the point was
it's like talking I want to do this to
you I'll do that to you maybe it's a 40
second by the way this is how conspiracy
there was a rumor out there I know
you're not I'm just don't come at me
they're like oh Alex Jones he's gay
right I'm like what are you talking
about why would you like what yeah I
heard about him at the at the Bohemian
thing and then the talk I'm like he's
not he's married with kids no no he's
like no I heard it was it's like this by
the way just so you know just so you
know the president of Microsoft we got
to wrap up the podcast we're 20 minutes
over the president of Microsoft the
president of Google every one of them
they said the biggest threat they're
concerned about moving forward is going
to be Ai and deep fakes deep fakes to be
specific okay deep fakes to be specific
let's explain somebody calls your mother
yeah and it's your voice and says hey
Mom I really need a thousand dollars if
you please give me the credit card yep
and mom gives it to you from your number
they've already had yours kidnap a girl
or or say they have her voice call them
say I'm kidnapped mommy give me money
yep sorry I interrupt you Patrick no no
Rob if you can find that let's play it
if not we got to finish the podcast the
guy said he pulled it from online after
he received nobody else has it from
legal action from talking and you're
saying nobody else I can't find it the
only thing I can find is the clip of
Alex talking about okay well then it's
all good Alex
yeah I'm glad we got you a simple
whiskey before you guys Alex this was a
a as usual very very entertaining
different than part one part one was a
different perspective this one is uh uh
we covered a bunch of different stores
we're gonna put the link to your book
below the uh great reset please link to
it at infowars.com we'll do that as well
Rob if you can put that below for people
to be able to find it uh uh I would say
go follow Alex on Twitter but I'm
so go to infowars.com to follow Alex's
content impressive please have me back I
look forward to it I look forward thank
you so much thank you everybody have a
great weekend bye-bye